Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Linus. Na, hast du schon deine Umschulung zum Russland-Experten begonnen.
Nee, ich bin noch nicht mal mit der Hochschulung auf Coronaexperte richtig fertig geworden.
Logbuch, Netzkritik mit der Folge vierhundertdreiundzwanzig vom dreiundzwanzigsten zweiten zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Und ähm Tim ist mal wieder nicht dabei und wir haben unseren lieben Thomas dabei,
mit dem wir heute ein bisschen über die klassischen Thomas Themen sprechen möchten, nämlich Österreich und das, was sich so auf der EU-Ebene im Bereich der Netzpolitik tut.
Ich muss jetzt auch natürlich Tim Würdig vertreten und über den,
HTTP Status Code 4hundertdrei2 sprechen. Die vierer Codes sind ja immer die Fehler bei einem Zugriff und der vier zwei drei ist
lockt also eine angefragte Ziel- oder Quellressource ist gegen,
gesperrt und warum ist das so? Weil man das quasi auch bei Web DAV nutzt, also bei einem Fallsystemzugriff und wenn da jetzt quasi mehrere auf einem.
Ressource zugreifen, die zum Beispiel äh quasi,
gerade von jemand anderem verändert wird, dann bekommt man eben zum Beispiel den Lock Code, dass also gesagt wird hier, es gibt äh neuen Inhalte, deswegen ist das Ding.
Ähm gerade gesperrt. Du kannst gerade nicht. Ähm,
darauf zugreifen. Allerdings findet man das relativ selten. Außerhalb von Web DAV, also,
ist ein Web DAV Ding und Web DAV ja weiß ich jetzt gar nicht ob das noch so,
der große Bringer ist. Ich kenne einige Leute, die das sehr äh sehr glücklich nutzen, aber,
weiß ich jetzt nicht ob das irgendwie die die Revolution war unbedingt.
Sind all diese Status kurz vergeben, weil ansonsten wäre jetzt der Zeitpunkt für manche Hörer sich so hintere Nummern zu sichern, um euch nachher zu treuen. Äh wenn ihr das jetzt wirklich durchzieht, egal wie sinnvoll es ist, ähm es ist ein Aufruf.
Ich glaube, das ist nur so eine Vierer-Nummer-Geschichte. Also es gibt ja, wir haben ja jetzt zum Beispiel oder ich glaube, wir haben auch hm, die wichtigen zweihunderter okay und äh hier diese Anfang drei, drei null vier, drei null zwei. Ich glaube, die haben wir damals auch behandelt.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir glaube ich noch bis bis mindestens in die 500er damit zu tun. Es wird noch eine eine wilde Zeit. Thomas, wann warst du eigentlich das letzte Mal bei uns.
Ach du ich war im Oktober, äh letzten Jahres das letzte Mal da. Äh ich habe nachgeschaut, Folge vierhundertzehn.
Und und das war die Sendung mit dem schönen Titel Status Kurz.
Äh wie's der Titel sagt, da ging's noch irgendwie da ging's grad erst los mit der Affäre, die dann zum Rücktritt von Bundeskanzler Sebastian Kurz geführt hat
Ähm der ist inzwischen weg. Das ist sehr schön. Ähm die Staatsanwaltschaft hat ihre Arbeit gemacht.
Das ist auch ähm ja eigentlich sehr beruhigend, wenn man sieht, dass die Justiz ähm sich da kein Blatt vorn Mund nimmt und sogar so mächtige Menschen ähm ins äh in die Ermittlungen kommen und,
ja da gab's wirklich so schwerwiegende Vorwürfe, dass am Ende er,
alle Ämter zurückgelegt hat und ähm zuerst hat er noch versucht, sich irgendwie im Hintergrund zu halten. Inzwischen hat er eine Rückkehr in die Politik ausgeschlossen. Und ähm
arbeitet bei Paulentier, also im Grunde bei äh Peter Thiel.
Im Moment arbeitet er bei Parante oder bei äh Till Capital?
Also er ist natürlich da direkt bei ähm Peter Thiel, ich glaube,
ähm haben wir hier auch schon mal geredet in der Sendung. Ähm also der frühe Facebook-Investor, der auch bei PayPal dabei war, ähm den man in der Netzpolitik vor allem auch deswegen kennt, weil er ähm die Firma Parantier mit jemand anderen
gegründet hat ähm und äh auch Trump Supporter ist und jemand, der sich politisch ja auch kein Blatt vor den Mund nimmt.
Ja ich äh habe den mal getroffen tatsächlich bei einer Konferenz. Absolut angenehmer Zeitraum. Das ist so ein richtiger Sympath,
Ähm der wirklich äh ja äh äußerst äh verstörende politische Ansichten hegt
und ähm es gibt ja offenbar irgendwie so diese neue Gilde der der Millionäre äh der Milliardäre die dann irgendwie durchdrehen ne. Also Elon Musk ist ja auch ähm ein ein ganz langsam sich entfaltendes ähm,
äh ähm Hyper Loop Reck ja und ähm,
dieser Tier hat ja jetzt äh sich aus aus dem Facebook Aufsichtsrat äh zurückgezogen.
Um ähm seine Energie, seine Zeit,
dem Erfolg von Donald Trump zu widmen und dem der politischen Revolution, die er anrollt.
In äh es gab jetzt vor Kurzem eine äh neo ach nee heißt ja gar nicht mehr, neo Magazin oder ein äh Böhmermann äh Böhmermann äh Folge zu ihm. Typisch halt relativ oberflächlich,
und dann äh haben sie ihn irgendwie so in so einem bond Bösewichtstil äh stilisiert, weil er mit Parantier ja eben.
Überwachungs äh Technologie ähm für Polizei und Staat äh fördert,
mit äh durch seine Facebook-Teilhaberschaft natürlich. Also es ist alles so so diese diesen unangenehmen die Gesellschaft kontrollieren, Macht ausüben, manipulieren, Bereichen äh da ist der irgendwie immer nicht weit.
Das ist also ich meine, da muss man sich echt fragen wer ist jetzt blöder dran,
Deutschland oder Österreich, ja, wenn wir den Schröder, der ist danach zu Putin gegangen. Kurz geht zu Thiel.
Ach, also da nehmen wir uns nichts, das kann ich toppen. Also wir haben auch äh unser unser letzter sozialdemokratischer Kanzler und der vorherige äh sind irgendwie äh beide im im bei,
zumindest den staatsnahen Betrieben, also Christian Kern ist im Vorstand äh der russischen Staatsbahn. Wir haben einen ehemaligen ÖVP-Kanzler, der ähm äh
im Gazprom Vorstand ist, äh dann gibt's noch irgendwie beim paar Bandenleute, also äh äh ja Russland ist sehr gut da drin, sich äh österreichischer,
einzuverleiben und wir haben die russische Gas-und Ölnadel genauso tief äh in der Ader wie Deutschland. Also ähm ganz viele Pipelines-Enden im Nachfeld in Österreich und auch in der Deba,
jetzt hier merkt man das so ein bissel, aber wir wollten ja nicht über Russland reden.
Der Rücktritt von Kurz, den hat er eigentlich damit begründet, dass er jetzt keine Lust mehr hat, ne. Die waren alle nicht nett genug zu ihm.
Äh ja, er hat das auch begründet mit äh äh der Geburt seines äh ersten Sohnes. Also er ist Papa geworden und hat dann gemeint, er muss sich jetzt um die Familie kümmern und bei seiner Rücktrittsrede hat er auch gesagt, er holt jetzt seine Freundin vom Krankenhaus ab mit dem Baby,
und äh ja ein paar Wochen später hat er dann einen sehr gut bezahlten äh Job angenommen, der ihm,
sehr viel auch ins Ausland führen wird. Also man sieht auch gleich welches Vaterbild da mit transportiert wird. Ähm,
Die gute Sache ist, wir reden jetzt viel mehr über Palentier in Österreich, es gibt eine Reihe an parlamentarischen Anfragen, äh von den Sozialdemokraten, wer denn äh welches Ministerium denn so Kunde ist vom Palantier, also darüber wird jetzt wenigstens ein bisschen mehr geredet.
Ähm aber ja also der Abgang war nicht rühmlich und ich hoffe, dass das ähm.
Ein bisschen merken, dass solche Demagogen oder Leute, die nur äh Politik machen mit mit Botschaften nach außen, ohne wirklich für irgendwas zu stehen, ähm dass das nicht zukunftsorgig ist, aber das ist meine stille Hoffnung.
Ähm man muss natürlich vielleicht noch dazu sagen, also dass der Thiel sich für den interessiert, ist natürlich äh bezeichnend.
Was glaubst du, will der von ihm? Was kauft sich Peter Thiel, wenn er Sebastian Kurz anstellt? Das habe ich mich auch gefragt, weil den will doch keiner haben, der hat doch in so einen Korruptionsskandal an der Backe.
Eine ultrarechte Identifikationsfigur und ein ziemlich gutes ähm Adressbuch.
Und jemanden, der offensichtlich korrumpierbar ist, ja, äh das ist doch äh Spitze, ja? Also ich meine, so einen kleinen Korruptionskandälchen an der Backe. Ich meine, der Mann möchte äh
Donald Trump unterstützen Sie dadrin irgendwie den größten äh das größte
Ziel, was da jetzt irgendwie erreichen kann, der ist vierundfünfzig und äh Milliardär, ne? Also das sind das sind so die Menschen, die sich dann auch irgendwann hm sagen wir mal sehr genaue Gedanken darüber machen, was sie,
mit ihrer Zeit im Leben noch machen wollen, ja? Welchen Impact sie hinterlassen wollen.
Und ähm offensichtlich hat der Thiel äh da jetzt ein sehr klares Ziel für sich, ja, was er mit der Welt anfangen möchte und ähm mit den USA.
Ja und da ist doch so ein so ein Bubi wie der kurz, der ist doch äh ist doch in irgendwie ein Chorknabe gegen den Donald Trump,
kleiner kleiner Korruptionsskandal. Ich bitte dich.
Passt gut ins Team wahrscheinlich.
Der Pasta genau rein, ne? Das ist äh also solche Leute muss ja auch erstmal finden, ja. Also.
Darf ich noch gerne behalten. Also wir wollen ihn nicht zurück.
Also es ist äh absolut beängstigend, ne, dass äh dass so etwas dass so etwas passiert.
Aber dieser Fall ist auch eine gute Gelegenheit, um ähm wieder über,
äh einen einen noch laufenden Justizskandal in Österreich zu sprechen
weil zu diesem Rücktritt von Sebastian Kurz und auch zu dem Rücktritt von Heinz-Christian Strache und dem Zerfallen der ähm
rechten Regierungen Österreich mit mit FPÖ-Beteiligung K. Er wäre es nie gekommen ohne dem Ibiza-Video. Und,
die Person, die dieses Ibiza-Video maßgeblich ähm mitproduziert hat, heißt,
Julian H, Julian Hessen Thaler, inzwischen kann man seinen Namen sagen und äh ja, das ist so dieser Whistleblower-Fall, ähm den wir uns äh sehr intensiv angeschaut haben. Ich glaube, das war auch bei der letzten Sendung äh im Oktober schon Thema.
Ich würde da gerne wieder drüber sprechen, weil ähm letzte ja also.
Vielleicht muss man beim Anfang anfangen. Also was ist da passiert? Ähm wahrscheinlich haben viele Leute dieses Video gesehen, diese
diejenigen, ich glaube es waren acht, neun, zehn Minuten,
diesem Ibiza Video, wo man eben äh den den späteren Vizekanzler, Österreich, Sanskritian Strache, von der rechtsextremen Partei FPÖ äh in dieser Villa in Ibiza sieht, wie er,
mit recht viel Wodka am Tisch äh dieser angeblichen russischen Oligarchin Staatsaufträge,
wenn sie ihm nur die Kronenzeitung eine sehr große Boulevardzeitung in Österreich verschaffen könnte, damit sie die Wahl gewinnen,
und äh er ist da eben sehr nahe zu der Linie gegangen von Korruption, aber,
allem was man bisher weiß und das Video liegt ja inzwischen zu Gänze vor und ist im Ibiza Untersuchungsausschuss behandelt worden, war nichts in diesem Video selber,
illegal also nicht zur Strache gesagt hat war sozusagen über der Linie er war damals auch noch nicht Amtsträger und deswegen wär's auch schwierig gewesen für ihn,
zu versprechen. Ähm er war ja noch nicht in der Regierung, ja? Er war ja einfach nur Oppositionsführer.
Ähm wie man dann später erfahren hat gab's da aber einen Bodyguard von Strache, der wirklich ähm Material gesammelt hat, das sozusagen justiabel ist,
der hat sich an einen Anwalt gewendet, äh der dann zu Julian Hessenthaler gekommen ist und die beiden haben dieses Video produziert.
Ist dann ähm im im Sommer 2019 veröffentlicht worden. Die Regierung ist zerbrochen. Ah Hans-Christian Stache ist zurückgetreten.
Dann ist man sehr lange nichts passiert. Also dann dann wurde zwar neu gewählt, aber,
Ja die Strafverfolgungsbehörden haben sich wie man heute weiß mehr mit den Machern des Videos als mit der dort dargestellten Korruption beschäftigt.
Ja, das ich ich muss nochmal ganz kurz da einhaken. Also Moment, also,
Strache ist Strache, klar. Jetzt geht der der Bodyguard von Strache ist quasi der Initiale Whistleblower, sprich mit einem Anwalt und die beiden.
Sage ich mal, entwickeln die Idee der Videosituation mit Julian Hessenthaler.
Ähm ich glaube, dass der Bodyguard gar nichts von diesem Video wusste. Also der war wirklich nur ihr way-in und der Beleg dafür, dass es da eben Korruption gab. Äh die sie dann äh nachstellen wollten mit diesem Video. Ähm der.
Das ist nämlich das Wichtige und diesen Aspekt, den finde ich sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig. Und ich fand das ähm also diese.
Böhmermann Anspielung zu diesem Thema, die es damals ja gab, die ja dann irgendwie auch dazu führte, so ha, war das der Böhmermann, der da den äh Strache aufs Glatteis geführt hat oder so was, ne. Die fand ich damals schon so so ausgesprochen ärgerlich.
Weil es
von Anfang an dieses ganze Ding, dieser dieses ganze Geschehnis so geframed wurde, als wäre das letztendlich irgendwas, was ich in Videostreich.
Ja? Oder was was Verbotenes Gemeines den den in eine Hütte ähm.
Den Strache in eine Hütte zu schaffen und dort zu filmen, ja? Nur warum macht also es gibt ja einen Grund, warum man das mit den meisten Politikerinnen noch nicht einmal versucht.
Einfach weiß, dass die wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal mit der Oligarchen nach Ibiza fliegen und dass sie, wenn sie sich dann dort mit der unterhalten, ähm
sich irgendwie halbwegs ähm in Ordnung.
Vor allem.
Nicht versuchen.
Über über Stunden hinweg sitzen zu.
Kaufen oder irgendwelche.
Die ganze Zeit nur um Korruption geht. Nicht aufzustehen, nicht zu widersprechen, sondern immer nur aber wir können,
das und das machen und es gibt ja viele Großspender, die spenden dann an Vereine, damit's der Rechnungshof nicht mitbekommt und Novimatik zahlt alle diese ganzen Aussagen, die Klopper, die da drinnen sind, Journalisten sind die größten Huren auf dem,
hat Hans-Christian Strache auch gesagt. Ja, aber es zeigt halt einen.
Das kann er sagen. Das ist frei Meinungsäußerung.
Genau, genau und das das ist jetzt auch so relevant, weil ähm wir springen ein bisschen, aber,
Sebastian Kurz hat sich nachher auch wirklich schön abgeputzt, dass das was da in dieser Villa gesagt wurde, was Strache gesagt hat und das Bild der Medien, das da entstanden ist, das geht absolut
nicht, ja? Und dieser Anschein von Korruption, das geht alles überhaupt nicht und er ist auch bei seinem eigenen Skandal dann über die Aussagen gestolper,
so wie in den Chats. Das war ja alles auch ein Skandal rund um äh Chats innerhalb der ÖVP und innerhalb äh des des äh
innersten Zyklus von Kurz und da ist genauso ein Bild der Medien, eine Bereitschaft von Korruption und ein auch ein Frauenbild äh zum Ausdruck gekommen, ähm dass dann auch irgendwann mal moralisch ein Problem war. Also das war
sowohl etwas, wo er immer noch äh unter unter äh Verdacht steht und ermittelt wird. Es ist noch keine Anklage erhoben worden. Aber äh wo's auch eben um
ja einfach das das das gesellschaftliche und die politische Verantwortung geht. Darüber ist er genauso gestol.
Ja. Wie ist es denn jetzt.
Weitergegangen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, ähm auch in der letzten Sendung das erzählt, aber wir sollten's hier nochmal vor äh für die Vollständigkeit äh wiederholen. Es gab irgendwie mehr Untersuchungen,
darüber, wer denn dieses Video gemacht hat, die gemeinen Hunde, ja, der arme Strache.
Als dass er sich ernsthaft mit diesem Strahlhammer auseinandergesetzt hat. Okay, der ist dann da unter Tränen zurückgetreten ähm.
Ist wurde aber insgesamt äh sehr also erfolgreich einfach darauf hingearbeitet, dass das in den Medien so eine so eine Dolstoß oder sagen wir mal zumindest für diejenigen, die
der ähm schwarz violetten Koalition oder wie die damals noch hieß, nee schwarz-türkis, ne.
Äh türkisblau, türkis für die ÖVP, für die Konservativen und die FPÖ äh äh die rechtsextreme Partei ist.
Sorry ja ähm also der das das es zu so einer Dolchstoßlegende für diejenigen wurde äh ähm die an die an an diese Werte Werte äh glauben wollten oder?
Ja, natürlich und ähm man man hat da auch extrem viel spekuliert, wer stand hinter dem Ibiza-Video. Es gab äh Initial vor allem auch die die Vermutung, ob da ein ausländischer,
Nachrichten oder Geheimdienst dahinter steckt und oder ob es vielleicht der politische Mitbewerber war,
im Grunde äh kann man all diese Theorien jetzt getrost zur Seite schieben. Also ähm ich habe mich wie gesagt sehr intensiv mit dem Gerichtsakt beschäftigt von von Julian Hessenthaler,
äh wer da nicht irgendwie wir haben einen Großteil davon veröffentlicht durch in der letzten Sendung gesagt habe. Aber wer's
ähm äh die kompakte Version haben wirklich Empfehler auch sehr, die Sky Serie zu der Ibiza Affäre ähm die ist inzwischen auch schon erschienen und die ist sehr gut. Die ist sehr nah an,
der Version der Wahrheit, äh die die ähm ich auch glaube für für richtig halten zu können. Ich weiß es nicht.
Wir werden sie verlinken ich habe mir da ein Einmonat gesky Abo geholt und danach gleich wieder gekündigt. Es war es mir wert.
Findet man die inzwischen auf der Pirate Bay oder sowas? Wie heißt die Serie?
Ähm Ibiza, Sky.
Wie heißte denn Ibiza.
Die Ibiza Affäre. Die Ibiza Affäre heißt.
Finde ich nichts auf.
Serie.
Genau, wir verlinken mal hier einfach den ähm Wikipedia Artikel davon. Ich hoffe sehr, dass das bald ähm auch auf anderen Plattformen zur Verfügung ist, weil das sollten die Leute wirklich sehen. Es ist ähm.
Hilfreich, um um einordnen zu können,
Es haben auch einige Leute die beteiligt waren an dieser ganzen Affäre der Anwalt Ramin M und und und Julian Hessenthaler haben da glaube ich auch beraten zur Seite gestanden. Ähm,
Ja, also.
Wo wo wo ist man dann denn da denn heute? Also am Ende des Tages äh haben sie ähm haben da dann sehr viele Ermittler ihre Arbeit aufgenommen, nachdem dieses Video,
herauskam. 20 Beamtinnen und Beamte waren für die sogenannte Sokotape,
abgestellt, die sich mit diesem Fall beschäftigt. Wir wissen heute, dass 17 davon ähm versucht haben, die Hintermänner des Videos herauszufinden und drei äh Beamtinnen sich mit den korrupten Politikern beschäftigt.
Ah Thomas, immerhin.
Na warte, es wird besser. Ähm es ist es ist inzwischen auch so, dass die handelnden Personen, ja das sind zwei zu nennen, Nico R ähm ein ein ein Polizeibeamter, der ähm
da an mehreren Stellen ganz zentral war, weil der hat zum Beispiel den Anfangsverdacht
äh besorgt, weil man ist dann sehr schnell drauf gekommen, hm okay, warte, das ist ein Video, das verdeckt in Spanien aufgenommen wurde. Das ist in Spanien nicht illegal,
Das ist nichts, weswegen wir da irgendwen verfolgen können, dass die jetzt hier ein verdecktes Video gemacht haben. Ähm es ist inzwischen auch schon durch Deutsche und österreichische Gerichte bestätigt, ähm dass das Video als solches nicht illegal war.
Weil hier einfach überragendes öffentliches Interesse geltend gemacht wird.
Und äh deswegen hat Nico R den Anwalt von Heinz-Christian Strache einvernommen und der hat doch gesagt, ja mein Mandant ist erpresst worden mit dem Video.
Dieser Vorwurf hat sich nie bestätigt, ist auch nie zur Anklage gebracht worden, aber war dann das erste äh Delikt, mit dem man,
äh rechtfertigen konnte, wieso man jetzt gegen diese Leute ermittelt
und vor allem ist Erpressung eine sogenannte Katalog-Straftat, das heißt, da kann ich auch in anderen EU-Ländern die dortigen Behörden,
was zu tun, ohne dass das durch äh mühsame Verwaltungs äh Prozesse durchgehen wird, so hm das ist bei uns illegal. Es ist auch dort illegal welcher Strafrahmen, welche Möglichkeiten haben wir da? Sondern nee, das ist in dem Katalog von Dingen, wo's einfach geht
über Grenzen hinweg zu ermitteln und das ist hier geschehen. Nico R hat sich auch berühmt gemacht, weil er äh Strache nach dessen Rücktritt das SMS geschickt hat. Äh äh ich hoffe auf einen Rücktritt vom Rücktritt und Kopf hoch.
Irgendwann einmal war Nico Ehre nicht mehr ähm tragbar und ist dann aus der Soko abgezogen worden. Inzwischen ist er befördert worden.
Und leite deine ganze Abteilung im Bundeskriminalamt. Äh sein Chef der Sokothep, Andreas Holzer.
Ist derjenige der ihn zuerst verteidigt hat und dann erst nach massivem öffentlichen Druck äh ähm Nico R abgezogen hat. Andreas Holzer ist deswegen auch relevant, weil,
Als der Anwalt äh Ramin M diesen äh ähm Bodyguard,
2015 schon irgendwie dessen dessen Informationen bekommen hat und der hat da wirklich so Fotos von Geldtaschen, also von Taschen voller Bargeld,
Strache zuzuschreiben sind gehabt, die ja der Polizei gezeigt hat, hat gemeint, ich habe da einen Mandanten, der hat.
Sehr viel Material, was äh auf Korruption in den höchsten Reihen hindeutet. Und Andreas Holzer hat aber einen ähm nur einen Aktenvermerk gemacht, der lückenhaft war,
das nie wieder nachher verfolgt. Andreas Holzer hat sich ähm ein bissel doch berühmt gemacht, weil er hat,
Peter Pilz, einen einen ähm,
ehemaligen Abgeordneten, der immer sehr aufdeckerisch unterwegs war. Dessen Buch hat er versucht einziehen zu lassen, sozusagen, ach, das sind Persönlichkeitsrechte verletzt und,
versuche dieses Buch jetzt sozusagen vom Markt zu nehmen. Andreas Holzer hat einen Kabarettisten im Zivilrechtswege verklagt der Prozess ist glaube ich noch anhängig,
Ja und dieser Mensch, der wirklich bissel kritisch zu bewerten ist, ist auch befördert worden und leitet jetzt das Bundeskriminalamt in Öster.
Junge, wo wohnst du da? Komm doch mal weg. Das ist doch gefährlich.
Wenn wenn die guten Leute gehen, dann ist es dann ist es aus.
Also das ist ja das ist.
Tschau bis Nathan. Aber aber äh das das ist auch ähm,
ein extrem besorgniserregendes Bild. Das wäre jetzt gerade sehen. Die ÖVP merkt,
das mit der Regierungsbeteiligung, daran haben wir uns die letzten Jahrzehnte echt gewohnt, das das war echt schön. Das wird vielleicht bald aufhören, weil das mit der Korruption, das checken die langsam,
und jetzt beginnen sie wirklich ohne jeder Schamposten zu besetzen.
Wir hatten letztens erst einen Fall, dass äh das Verteidigungsministerium ähm so einen Truppenübungsplatz, da war die Leitung ausgeschrieben. Es gab vier Bewerber.
Drei sehr gut qualifizierte und einen, den die Bewerbungskommission gesagt hat, na den nehmen wir lieber nicht, weil der hat eigentlich nicht das, was es braucht.
Die Verteidigungsministerin hat sich dann trotzdem für diese Person entschieden, die lustigerweise in der selben ÖVP,
Gruppe ist wie sie, der ÖAB, also einer der Mächtigen, Teilorganisationen der österreichischen Volkspartei. Nur ist es so, dass so militärische Besetzungen durch den Bundespräsidenten bestätigt werden müssen.
Das hat Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen zweimal verweigert mit Verweis drauf, der ist nicht der Bestqualifizierte. Die Fachkommission hat gesagt,
der ist der Einzige, das nicht werden darf. Äh Verteidigungsministerin Tanna hat dann einfach diese Person.
Interimistisch mit der Leitung des Truppenübungsplatzes betraut und das ist jetzt seit 18 Monaten der Status Quo. Also sogar da, wo's Jackson Balances gibt, werden die einfach dreist ignoriert.
Das ist, was Österreich gerade so beschäftigt, dass die ÖVP ist jetzt wirklich dabei, ihre Macht im Staat über Personen, die sie in in in äh gewisse,
Positionen hievt, zu zementieren und mich erinnert das immer mehr an das, was äh in Ungarn aufführt, dass was Orban gerade macht, der jetzt auch im März seine Wahl zu schlagen hat und,
in Österreich wenn man wacher Geist ist, schaut man sehr viel nach Ungarn, weil das sind die selben Playbox und,
Das ist halt wirklich zutiefst undemokratisch und gefährlich für den Rechtsstaat.
Und da müssen die Leute, die noch an den Rechtsstaat glauben, ganz entschieden dagegen auftreten. Ansonsten kann das sehr schnell gehen.
Und wie läuft's da gerade bei euch, als ich meine
Ganz ehrlich, Julian-Hessenthaler, vor Gericht äh war jetzt eigentlich gerade ein Urteil erwartet worden, die Urteilsverkündung beziehungsweise der Abschluss der Verhandlung hat sich da noch ein bisschen verschoben.
Was war da jetzt los?
Ja, so,
Julian-Hessenthaler ist ist äh für uns halt der der Fall, auf den wir uns auch als als Zivilgesellschaft, als Episenther Works äh konzentrieren, weil.
Ist halt sehr beispielhaft, das ist an ihm versucht man ein Exempel zu statuieren. Ähm und äh die die das Ermittlungsverfahren gegen ihn,
war wirklich nicht neutral geführt. Also man ich habe jetzt einen Teil davon erzählt äh es gab da schon eben ähm als der Prozess begann im September dieses Statement von 18 Menschenrechts-NGOs, darunter wirklich auch,
Electronic von Tierfoundation, Amnesty International, Whistleblowing International. Wir haben uns da große Namen und Kanonen gesucht als Schützenhilfe.
Auch um uns a bissel zu schützen, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, wenn wir uns zu dem Fall äußern.
Und ja wir sind seitdem im Gerichtssaal und verfolgen diesen Prozess. Eigentlich hätte ähm da schon ein Urteil passieren sollen.
Aber das ist äh dann am Ende doch nicht passiert, weil,
die Verteidigung drauf besteht, dass noch eine Zeugin einvernommen wird, die sich in Serbien befindet und äh scheinbar ist es auf dem Rechtshilfeweg recht schwierig so eine Videoschaltung mit Serbien hinzubekommen. Deswegen ist da
Ähm das Urteil noch nicht gesprochen. Das wird auf Mitte, Ende März erwartet und äh wir als wir damals rausgingen, war das wirklich so.
Hessentaler und dieses Ibiza bietet, die Leute wussten nicht so genau. Und das war immer noch so, die sind alle irgendwie und ich glaube auch, dass dieser Ibiza-Detektiv durchaus äh seine seine Trommelnummer gedreht hat im Leben
keine Frage. Äh sonst wäre der nicht so gut gewesen, dass er irgendwie Strache hinters Licht führt,
muss schon aus dem selben Wasser sein. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass äh er in der Zeit, wo er dieses Video gemacht hat, auch noch mit Drogen gedealt hat nebenher.
Am Ende des Tages äh ist halt das, was die ähm Staatsanwaltschaft vorbringt zwei Belastungszeugen nicht mehr. Es gibt keine Sachbeweise, keine also Fingerabdrücke und und DNA-Spuren will die Verteidigung die ganze Zeit, dass man ab,
von Drogenpräsen, die angeblich operiert äh worden sollen sein von von den Beschuldigten. Hat der Richter bisher abgelehnt,
Also man hat nur diese zwei Belastungszeugen, die sich gegenseitig widersprechen, die sich in ihren eigenen Aussagen widersprechen, wenn man die über die Zeit liest.
Und äh die eine Zeugin äh hat eben elfmal bei der Polizei ausgesagt, ohne Dolmetscher,
Bei Gericht hat es drei Anläufe gebraucht äh und an Dolmetscher am Ende, damit man sie einvernehmen konnte.
Die Zeugnisfähigkeit wurde zwar in der letzten Sitzung des Gerichts von einer Sachverständigen bejaht. Sie hat aber auch gesagt, äh dass da immer wieder.
Auch Aussagen von ihr, also wenn man ihr Suggestivfragen stellt, wird sie immer bejahen. Einfach weil ähm deutsche Sprachen eben nichts, was sie.
Sie versucht darüber hinweg zu täuschen, weil die Aussage der Sachverständigen.
Was halt auch irgendwie nicht so gut ist, wenn das so eine von zwei Belastungszeugen ist. Und der zweite Belastungszeuger hat mehrmals gesagt, Hessentaler war nicht sein Dealer.
Und hat dann erst in der letzten Einvernahme, wo's so hieß, kriege ich eine Fußfessel, ja okay, er war's.
Die haben ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen äh Konto äh Eingänge gehabt diese Zeugen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ne.
Genau, es gibt bestätigte Zahlungen.
Es gibt keine es gibt keine Belastungszeugen die nicht irgendwie ungewöhnlich hohe Kontoeingänge hatten so im was war das niedriger fünfstelliger Bereich von.
55.000 Euro äh sind nachweislich und unbestritten, bezahlt worden von einem der Novomatik, einem großen Glücksspiel genau.
Zahlt alle. Das sind doch diese Nevomatik, oder?
Also wer ist nur Romatik? Nuromatik ist ein sehr großer Multimilliarden-Glücksspielkonzern aus Österreich, der also wenn ihr schon mal irgendwie so einen einarmigen Banditen oder so diese dummen Wettmaschinen hattet, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die von Noromatik kommen, recht groß.
Das ist ein Unternehmen, das die Multimilliardia Martin Graf gehört, äh der eben auch ÖVP und FPÖ nahe steht und der ähm,
persönlich Hausdurchsuchungen hatte durch die Ibiza Affäre, dann haben sie das Handy weggenommen, der ist selber,
mehrmals jetzt geladen worden in Prozessen, involviert, äh die Novomatik hat auch
A A ähm was ihre Kontrolle der Kasinosaustrick betrifft an die äh tschechische Saskia-Gruppe äh einige Sachen abtreten müssen im Zuge dieser Affäre. Also da
ging wirklich viel für die verloren. Es wäre nicht ausgeschlossen, dass die eine Rechnung offen haben, die sie begleichen wollen würden, indem sie,
einem einem der ähm Blogger wird er immer genannt, der sogenannte äh Professor Gerd Schmidt.
Der sehr viel veröffentlicht auf seiner Seite EU Infothek über diese ganze Ibiza Sache.
Der halt eben auch Beraterverträge mit den Belastungszeugen hatte und da weiß man, dass dafür wie eben Beratungsgespräche von wenigen Stunden 55.000 Euro gezahlt wurden.
Die Anwaltskosten in dem Prozess der Belastungszeugen, die ja selber schon wegen Drogendelikten verurteilt sind,
hat äh äh Gerd Schmidt eben auch die Anwaltskosten übernommen. Also das ist ein Naheverhältnis, was nicht gesund ist. Und das ist nur die Kurzfassung. Wir verlinken noch irgendwie.
Warum zahlt er? Warum zahlt er irgendwelchen Junkies, Kohle.
Ja weil.
Die oder oder Drogenhändlern oder was auch immer, die da.
Weil er rausfinden wollte, wer bei Ibiza dahinter steckt und äh.
Und da fragt man Junkies.
Ja das also der eine ähm äh die eine Person war schon.
Bekannter Polizei ähm Spitzel oder Informant. Ich weiß nicht, was der richtige Begriff ist.
Hat mit äh Julian-Hessenthaler in derselben Firma gearbeitet. Es war ein Mitarbeiter von.
Die kannten sich schon, der wusste schon Dinge über Hessenthaler. Das waren schon Leute, wo er gegraben hat, die äh ihm weiterhelfen konnten äh und am Anfang wusste man wirklich wenig drüber, wer wer das wieder gemacht hat. Der ist schon.
Aber warte mal ganz kurz Thomas, ich ey das sind Menschen und die haben irgendwie Geld bekommen. Warum wofür brauchten die denn Geld?
Ja, du äh vor allem äh EU-Infothek hat keinerlei äh da ist kein Geschäftsmodell ersichtlich, ja. Schon große Medien schaffen es nicht, für Informationen zu bezahlen
aus gutem Grund auch, aber man kriegt von denen kein Geld ähm und die haben auch oft heutzutage kein Geld mehr, irgendwelche Honorare für Quellen zu bezahlen.
Das äh Herr Schmidt das tun kann und vor allem in diesem hohen Umfang.
Ist schon fragwürdig und äh das Problem ist aber, jetzt kommen wir wieder zum österreichischen Rechtsstaat zurück. Ähm äh Julian-Hessenthaler sitzt seit über einem Jahr im Gefängnis.
Also der ist im Dezember 2020 in Berlin festgenommen worden, war dann einige Monate in Auslieferungshaft. War noch irgendwie beim Wirecard-Untersuchungsausschuss in Deutschland geladen,
und ist dann nach Österreich überstellt worden und dort sitzt er jetzt in Untersuchungshaft,
und äh es gab auch den Antrag einer Enthaftung, einfach zu sagen, okay ähm das hat sich alles nicht substanziert,
wieso kann der nicht mit Fußfessel irgendwie nach Hause während der Hauptverhandlung über die Schuldfrage entschieden wird.
Äh ja die Gerichte haben gemeint, nein darf er nicht,
weil man kann heutzutage ja auch Drogen übers Internet verkaufen und deswegen besteht eine eine Tatbegehungsgefahr.
Er hat ja seine Auslieferung nach Österreich mit Rechtsmitteln bekämpft,
Deswegen äh ist auch von einer Fluchtgefahr auszugehen, das war mir auch neu, dass ein Rechtsmittel gegen eine Auslieferung dann später eine Fluchtgefahr sein kann. Ich dachte, dass er auch ganz normal zulässig, dass man,
die rechtsstaatlichen Wege ausnutzt und aber das das das I-Tüpfelchen ist, dass ähm die Widersprüche der Belastungszeugen,
vom Gericht auch nicht entlastend gewertet werden weil in Drogenverfahren ist es ja üblich, dass sich Belastungszeugen widersprechen.
Sonst nicht. Sonst geht man damit anders um, ne?
Im Zweifel für den Angeklagten du musst dich einfach fragen, reicht das oder reicht das nicht für einen Schuldspruch?
Ich ich kann vieles nicht nachvollziehen in dem Verfahren, deswegen schauen wir auch darauf, dass da.
Ja, dass die Öffentlichkeit dann nicht verloren geht im Gerichtssaal, dass irgendwie Leute mitbekommen, was da passiert.
Und dann wird man halt sehen, ob Österreich ähm seinen Platz in der westlichen Demokratie noch verdient oder nicht. Aber ähm man zweifelt.
Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt das ganz ich meine gut.
Privatdetektive sind jetzt äh häufig
sage ich mal, durch kreative äh Methoden bekannt, ja und ähm es mag jetzt durchaus sein, dass der äh vielleicht auch äh um meine finanzielle,
Lücke zu schließen, seine Privatdetektivfähigkeiten im äh Handel mit äh mit kreativen oder Bewusstseinserweiternden oder verbotenen Substanzen. Äh irgendwie
bestritten hat, ja ähm.
Und selbstverständlich äh gehört so etwas im Zweifelsfall verfolgt. Ich kann mir nur irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass andere Leute, die vielleicht das gleiche Vergehen begangen haben,
Zeugen äh gegen sich haben, die fette, fünfstellige Geldeingänge aufm Konto haben,
die sich widersprechen, die Sprachbarrieren haben und denen, die mit Suggestivfragen verhört wurden
ja? Wie gesagt, das wird das Gericht wird das schon sicherlich finden, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, ich glaube, es geht da um den Handel mit einem Kilogramm Kokain oder was wird ihm da zu last gelegt?
Also es sind 1,2 Gramm Kilo, Kokain mit einem Höchststrafmaß von 15 Jahren.
Okay, das ist eine große, also das ist eine große Menge. Das ist äh ähm.
Sagen wir mal Eigenbedarf wird schwierig zu argumentieren. Wobei ich auch gehört habe, dass das äh argumentiert wurde. Hm sagen wir mal Eigenbedarf des erweiterten Freundeskreises in gewissen Schichten ähm De.
Musste Strache hinters Licht führen, das war die minimale Menge.
Irgendwie muss man den Strache ja auch die paar Stunden nach Ibiza den Flug überstehen lassen, ne. Ähm okay, wie dem auch sei.
Ich glaube, dass äh kaum jemand ähm einen derartigen.
Strafverfolgungsdruck hat, ja und vor allem bezahlte Zeugen gegen sich hat, ja. Jetzt ist es natürlich gleichzeitig so, dass in diesen in diesen Drogenhandelsgeschichten natürlich geht's.
Gibt es die Straffreiheit, wenn man den nächsten Übersicht äh verrät und da fragt man sich natürlich jetzt wiederum, hm.
Also mit 1,2 Kilo bist du auf jeden Fall noch nicht irgendwie der große King Pin, ja. Ähm deswegen würde ich halt eigentlich erwarten, dass jemand dem anderthalb Kilo zur Last gelegt werden.
Und da irgendwie 5zehn Jahre im Raum stehen, dass der schon jemanden findet, der vielleicht zehn Kilo oder zwanzig oder hundert gehandelt hat und den ans Messer liefert, ja. Insofern kommt mir das alles so ein bisschen ähm.
Komisch vor und was unabhängig davon glaube ich ist, ist einfach diese.
Erkenntnis, so gehen wir mal davon aus, dass der äh diesen Handel begangen hat, ja? Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass ich weiß gar nicht, was so der durchschnittliche äh Konsum.
Die durchschnittliche Konsummenge dieser Droge in Wien oder in Berlin ist, aber ich würde schätzen, mit einem Kilo wirst du den Markt da nicht großartig fluten, so. Ähm.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das alles stimmt, dann.
Ist es doch so, dass wir hier es mit jemandem zu tun haben, der mit Sicherheit nicht mit sehr großer Sicherheit nicht.
Diese Strafverfahren in dem Ausmaß in der Intensität hätte, wenn er nicht diese Julian,
Hessetaler, Ibiza, Verflechtungen.
Hätte. Der hätte sich keiner drauf äh keiner für interessiert. Der hätte vielleicht irgendwann mal die Polizei gesagt, komm hier der Typ mit dem ein Kilo da kommen wir irgendwie nicht weiter. Haben wir widersprüchliche Aussagen stellen wir das Verfahren ein.
Ja?
Ähm und auch eine ähnliche Sache, jetzt lehne ich mich hier wieder weit aus dem Fenster. Ja, wie viele Jahre Julian Assange mit einem sehr,
Widersprüchlichen Fall, die ähm oder ähm facettenreichen Fall ähm.
Als Damoklesschwert über sich lebte. Wo wo übrigens auch Video ähm Vernehmungen eine Rolle spielten und die tatsächliche Unmöglichkeit.
Die irgendwie äh einzurichten. Wenn wir uns anschauen, dass jemand wo etwa wie Edward Snowden irgendwie in Moskau lebt, weil er irgendwie sich nirgendwo anders mehr einen Fuß auf den Boden treten kann,
dann,
Ist doch die Botschaft oder das Exempel, was hier statuiert wird, schon einfach sehr offensichtlich. Damit will ich jetzt nicht irgendwelche ähm,
Drogenhandel vergehen legitimieren, aber es ist doch sehr klar, dass hier eine ähm.
Ungleichbehandlung stattfindet mit dem Ziel der Diskreditierung dieser Person.
Damit die gesamte Ibiza-Affäre in Verruf bringen,
und vor allem auch das Signal an alle, die irgendwo so sagen wir mal von Sachen äh Kenntnis erlangen, so die Botschaft zu senden.
Wir finden was, ist auch völlig egal und wir ruinieren dich einfach, du wirst deines Lebens nicht mehr froh.
Und das ist ja eigentlich die einzige Botschaft, die du da draußen brauchst. An an sehr viele Leute, die danach eben oder auch in so grausamen
Vorgehen äh wie das gegen Reality Winner stattfindet, ja? Das du brauchst einfach nur lass dir mal ihre Geschichte erzählen,
Lasst sie mal ihre Dokus drehen. Darüber äh wie wie scheiße sie behandelt werden. Lass sie mal verurteilt werden. Lasst jemanden einen halben Jährchen in Untersuchungshaft sitzen. Lasst es mal immer wieder schön Berichterstattung darüber geben. Lasst die mal den Misskredit
bringen. Das also das ist doch so erkennbar.
Was da stattfindet und auch so furchteinflößend, ja? Muss ich ja auch ganz ehrlich sagen, dass man die die Botschaft das gesehen zu haben
verstanden zu haben, damit hast du dir die nächsten fünf bis zehn Whistleblower erstmal gespart bis es irgendjemanden gibt, der wieder meint äh dass er oder sie äh eine ausreichend weiße Weste hätte, um,
sich den den Mut zusammenzureißen äh vielleicht mal auf einen Missstand ähm hinweisen zu können und ja,
Letztendlich heißt es die Botschaft so ja wir finden was, wir machen dich fertig. Egal was und gleichzeitig,
ist es ja auch gewissermaßen unerheblich für den Skandal. Äh,
aber also es ist inhaltlich in unerheblich für den Skandal, aber natürlich nicht in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung wenn man eben sagt, ja hier das war irgend so ein Kokainhändler, der da in in Ibiza eine Bude verwanzt, Alter. Was ist denn das für Leute?
Das ist natürlich die die andere Botschaft. Insofern äh kann man sich echt riesige Sorgen um den armen äh Mann machen, ne.
Die Sky-Serie ist da wieder die Empfehlung, um irgendwie so ein bissel nachzuvollziehen und dieses Bild ist dort auch nicht nur ein rosiges. So ähm ich glaube, dass da durchaus auch äh ähm viel Glück
dabei war, aber der entscheidende Faktor ist genau der, den du jetzt angesprochen hast, nämlich diese abschreckende Effekt, dieser Chilling-Effekt auf die nächsten Aufdecker und Whistleblower erinnern. Also das ist.
Die nachhaltige Konsequenz von so etwas und da komme ich auch wieder drauf zurück. Das das Österreich halt,
ähm ein Land ist das letzte europäische Land ohne Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Also nicht nur das letzte EU-Land, ja, dass so was nicht hat, sondern auch in Europa, im Sinne von Council of Europe Definition, die die Türkei inkludiert. Ähm sind wir das letzte Land, wo die die Bevölkerung nicht das Recht hat.
Nach Dokumenten des Staates zu fragen. Ähm das heißt ganz oft brauchst du Leute, die innerhalb der Institutionen sind, Missstände mitbekommen und das unter einem,
nicht unerheblichen Einsatz für ihre Karriere und manchmal eben sogar auch für ihre Freiheit oder für ihr Leben,
auf sich nehmen, diese Dinge öffentlich zu machen. Und an der Stelle sei auch noch mal, ich bin.
Immer der Fan von strukturellen Lösungen. Es gibt eine EU-Richtlinie zum Schutz von Westleblauern.
Die in den allermeisten Ländern noch nicht umgesetzt wird. Die versucht wenigstens bei diesem Thema ähm bisschen Meter zu machen und ein Framework aufzubauen. Das ist eben einen sicheren Weg
braucht wie Menschen, die innerhalb von Institutionen Missstände melden, dass die eben straf- und zivilrechtlich möglichst wenig wenn wenn gar nichts sich zu befürchten hätten.
Die verdienen unseren Schutz
Und äh da, da, da, da muss man auch irgendwie viel mehr hinschauen und äh solche lauten Fälle wie jetzt der von dem Ibiza Macher, die schaden ganz einfach dem dem ähm,
den Mut von den Nächsten, die da kommen und ja, also wir werden im März sehen, ob's dazu äh einem einem Urteil kommt. Ähm.
Und wir werden sicherlich im Gerichtssaal sein, dass Epi-Center Workshop und werden auch darüber berichten ähm vielleicht auch hier.
Kommen wir zur lustigeren Themen in Linus. Ähm wir ja ähm äh die die nächsten zwei Themen äh schließen an
an vorherige Sendungen. Also ähm äh ich habe als äh Pflückke und Kantorkel hier waren mir schon gedacht, so dass wir den Datenskandalen, die peinlich sind, das können wir auch.
Wir hatten im Dezember und Jänner ein paar lustige Datenskandale. Das eine war ähm,
äh des epidemiologische Meldesystem.
Wie kann man das erklären? Das ist ein Meldesystem, in dem ähm Krankheiten eingetragen werden, sowas wie HIV, so was wie Syphilis, ähm.
Und auch Tollwut, ja, also gefährliche Krankheiten, wenn die diagnostiziert werden durch einen Arzt, durch ein Labor, da müssen die gemeldet.
Du kannst dir denken, in so einer Pandemie sind solche ähm IT-Systeme auf einmal super wichtig und äh so so,
früher 2000er Datenbanken, wo lange keiner mehr drauf geschaut hat, werden auf einmal zentrale Tools und die Zahlen, die da rauskommen, werden in den Hauptnachrichten berichtet.
Und äh dieses epidemiologische Meldesystem war auch in Österreich eben äh ein ein ein wichtiger Punkt in dem Pandemiemanagement.
Wie das so ist, ähm diese ähm diese diese Zertifikate äh mit denen man in dieses System einsteigen kann als Labor haben ihren Weg gefunden von einzelnen Laboren hin zu,
einer,
Leistungsfirma, die die Daten für dieses Labor eingegeben hat, weil das waren einfach so viele Corona-positiv-Fälle, äh deswegen hat man sich entschieden, wir lagern das mal aus. Dieses Unternehmen hat dann auch noch mal ausgelagert an eine andere Firma,
in der Summe waren dann äh nicht wirklich eingeschulte äh oder zu Verschwiegenheit verpflichtete Personen, die auf ihrem Privatrechner,
Zugangsschlüssel, also das Kleinsalz-Zertifikat zum Einstieg in dieses epidemiologische Meldesystem bekommen haben und gleich auch noch Excel-Files mit allen positiv corona-getesteten Menschen,
auch wieder unverschlüsselt auf ihrem Privatgerät zugeschickt bekommen haben.
Ähm ja über dieses System konnte man recht viele Daten rausziehen, man konnte sie aber auch manipulieren, man hätte jeden Menschen da irgendwie eine Coronaerkrankung eintragen können.
Oder auch ein HIV oder nachschauen welche Politiker vielleicht HIV hat und solche Dinge, das wäre alles gegangen über diesen Zugang.
Und ähm da hat sich dann eben ein Whistleblower gemeldet beim Standard und bei uns und ähm wir haben dann ähm ja bestätigt, dass dieser dieser Zugriff wirklich existiert. Auch ein kleines Video gemacht von,
diesen Zugriff und hatten das dann äh veröffentlicht, dass recht große Wellen geschlagen hat.
Und dann haben wir auch darauf hingewiesen, dass da durchaus jetzt Blödsinn in dieser wichtigen Datenbank drinnen steht und Österreich hat ja eine Impfpflicht, die es einführen will,
eine Impfpflicht, die noch dazu wirklich auf Knopfdruck ähm äh alle Menschen, die nicht geimpft und nicht genesen sind, kriegen eine Verwaltungsstrafe.
Also es wäre wichtig, dass diese Daten richtig sind,
wenn wir diese äh Impfpflicht wirklich mal vollends umsetzen. Das ist noch ein bissel unklar, aber das Gesetz sieht in der Phase drei genau so eine automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung vor.
Wir haben dann ein ein Formular zur Verfügung gestellt, wie Leute eine Datenschutzauskunft stellen können, um wenigstens zu wissen, was über sie selber denn
gespeichert ist in dieser Datenbank. Das Gesundheitsministerium,
einfach nicht reagiert und hat diese Auskunftsversuche nicht beantwortet ähm gemeinsam mit neu mit der NGO von Mark Schröms helfen wir den Leuten jetzt nochmal Beschwerden einzureichen.
Wenigstens die wenigen Betroffenen, die's wissen wollen, herausfinden, ähm was da über Sie in dieser Gesundheitsdatenbank drinnen steht.
Das ist Skandal Nummer eins.
Ja weil warte mal, vielleicht müsstest du noch ganz kurz,
äh eure Impfpflicht kurz erklären, was da jetzt grade in in Österreich geplant ist, einfach mal aus Interesse, ist ja eine Diskussion, die auch in Deutschland äh ja geführt wird. Ähm.
Dadurch, dass es keine zentralen Register gibt und 40 Millionen zu viel ausgestellte Impfzertifikate äh erübrigt sich die eigentlich. Äh hm was wird da genau in Österreich jetzt gemacht?
Also ähm in einer ähm äh spätabendlichen Sitzung,
mit den dem der Bundesregierung, mit den Landeshauptleuten also die Landeschefin Österreich, die ist nun wirklich so, ähm hat man sich geeinigt eine Impfpflicht zu machen, weil das war sozusagen der Tag, wo man sich eingestanden hat
Shit. Wir müssen echt noch mal zusperren. Wir brauchen noch einen Lockdown. Die Zahlen gehen durch die Decke, wir haben die Kontrolle verloren.
Man nicht nochmal einen Lockdown irgendwann später machen muss. Hat's geheißen, okay.
Wir machen jetzt eine Impfpflicht, dass wirklich nicht nur einzelne Berufsgruppen oder Altersgruppen, sondern wirklich alle Menschen, äh die die theoretisch geimpft werden können,
gestraft werden, wenn sie keine Impfung gesetzt bekommen haben.
Äh Österreich hat äh seit 2019 schon ein elektronisches Impfregister diskutiert und dieses auch ähm im ersten Jahr der Pandemie 2020 umgesetzt. Das läuft auch schon. Das ist bei der Elke angesiedelt. Also
Da wurde unser Gesundheitsakten auch schon liegen und ist verpflichtend für alle Menschen und für alle Impfungen, auch für die,
Zeckenimpfung, die eigentlich nicht gegen eine Fremdgefährdung der Krankheit ist, aber die Daten hatte man sozusagen schon.
Die Daten äh über die Impfungen, die ausgeteilt werden, die Daten über die Genesungen, die passiert sind und ähm.
Ja das Gesetz ist auch ähm wir waren da auch in Beratungen eingebunden. Also da hat man wirklich versucht mit einem inklusiven Prozess,
die formalen Sachen richtig zu machen und wir haben immer gesagt so ähm wir schauen uns nur den Datenschutz an zu den anderen Sachen.
Äußern wir uns nicht. Ich kann da auch wirklich beide Seiten sehr gut verstehen. Also das,
körperliche Unversehrtheit eines der Dinge ist, wo der Staat einfach nichts hinein zu regieren hat, wo wo's einfach Grenzen geben muss und auf der anderen Seite, dass äh die Impfung der einzige Weg raus aus dieser Krise ist und.
Wir hatten Impfpflichten in der Vergangenheit schon in Österreich ähm gegen.
Äh es wäre insofern ähm vertretbar jetzt hier auch diesen Schritt zu gehen.
Aber ja, so obwohl die Impfpflicht jetzt formal auch schon gilt in Österreich, hat sich ja der Impfquote nicht wirklich was verbessert. Das ist ähnlich wie in Deutschland, glaube ich.
Da fehlen einfach noch so ähm fünfundzwanzig, dreißig Prozent Hartgesottene und ähm die hat man bisher einfach noch nicht erreicht,
Diese Impfpflicht ist aber jetzt eher noch so etwas Theoretisches, die in in der nächsten Phase wird, die dann ähm ein bissel schärfer geschalten, sodass die Polizei bei,
Kontrollen so was wie ähm weiß nicht Fahrzeugkontrolle, gehen sie mal irgendwie Führerschein, Zulassungsschein und ihr Impfzertifikat her. So was könnte dann passieren. Das ist die Polizei kann Random anfangen, das zu kontrollieren,
Wer nicht ähm geimpft ist oder ein anderer Begründung hat, wie so er eben schon genesen ist oder.
Man will jetzt auch eigene QR-Codes machen für Ausnahmen von der Impfpflicht, wenn man nicht geimpft werden kann äh aufgrund einer ärztlichen, eines ärztlichen Attests kriegt man auch so einen QR-Code, den man dann herzeigen kann in der Situation.
Und ja, also das ist so der Weg, den man, den man ziemlich sicher gehen wird, ob die Phase drei kommt, dass man wirklich jetzt mit diesen zentralisierten Datenbanken.
Automatisierte Rechtsdurchsetzung macht, dass man auf Knopfdruck ermittelt, wer ist noch nicht geimpft und die können jetzt mal irgendwie einen Brief und dann kriegen sie einen zweiten Brief und beim dritten Brief müssen sie 600 Euro Strafe zahlen,
wer diese Strafe beeinsprucht, da sind's dann gleich 2000 Euro Strafe.
Das ist aus meiner Sicht ganz klar überschießend und ist auch ein ganz gefährlicher Schritt wenn wir jetzt aufgrund einer Datenlage automatisiert Strafen ausstellen.
Das kennen wir vielleicht maximal so bei Parkstrafen oder wenn man zu schnell gefahren ist, dass das automatisierte Systeme sind.
Und das in der Masse einzusetzen, wo man weiß, es wird zigtausende Force-Positives geben.
Das ist schon wirklich ähm ein auch ein Ausdruck von Hilflosigkeit des Staates.
Und deswegen wird da auch sehr viel gestritten. Also man muss auch sagen in die Stimme, die sagen, dass mit der Impfpflicht war echt eine schlechte Idee. Wir sollten das wieder abblasen. Die werden immer lauter. Und äh ich würde da jetzt kein Geld mehr drauf wetten, dass das so kommt, wie's beschlossen wurde.
Die.
Diskussion. Grade ist ja, ich meine, wir haben jetzt diese Omikron-Welle in Deutschland flaut sie jetzt ab. Ähm natürlich denken jetzt wieder alle erst vorbei, ja.
Corona ist vorbei und warum brauchen wir jetzt noch eine Impfpflicht, ne? Dann gibt's wiederum andere, die sagen, na ja, wenn du jetzt einführst, dann hast du potenziell eine Möglichkeit davon im
ähm September äh Oktober, November, wenn der Herbst kommt und die fallenden Temperaturen und die potenziell nächste Welle,
kannst du da davon profitieren. Insofern ist kommt ja erschwerend jetzt zu einer Impfpflicht-Diskussion eben diese ihre antizyklische Natur.
Hinzu ja das würde ich hier nur gerne nochmal für die Chronistische äh Geschichte.
Anmerken für die Einordnung nach vielen vielen Jahren, dass wir jetzt.
Gerade nicht uns in einer Situation befinden, in der äh also wir befinden uns in einer Situation mit sehr vielen Infektionen, aber mit nicht so viel.
Ähm Hospitalisierungsrate, ähm was natürlich dann auch wieder, weil die Leute auf die Jetzt-Situation blicken. Äh ja, entsprechende
ja nicht nicht zu dringende Notwendigkeit sieht äh darstellt in das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass daran, dass das Ding einfach dann.
Im Sande verläuft, oder.
Absolut, also die Zahlen in Österreich sind sehr ähnlich wie in Deutschland, also äh erschreckend hohe Fallzahlen, aber in den Krankenhäusern ähm gibt's auch einigermaßen gut zu
Also ich höre das auch von Menschen, die dort arbeiten, also es ist nimmer so schlimm, wie es vorher schon mal war.
Trotz der hohen Infektionszahlen und das das führt natürlich auch dazu, dass die Leipzig denken, hm das mit der Impfpflicht ist das wirklich so eine gescheite Idee. Wir haben jetzt auch schon Impfleugner-Parteien, die es auf erschreckend hohe Werte äh schaffen bei.
Also ähm MFG heißen die und da steht für Menschen äh ähm
Wie war das Menschenfreiheit, Grundrechte? Ich hab's ich verdränge das immer. Ähm ähm äh MFG.
Stehen den nochmal Menschenfreiheit, Grundrechte, ja doch ich hatte Recht.
Heißt mit freundlichen Grüßen. Auf Wiedersehen.
Ja, auf Wiedersehen wäre eigentlich.
Vorzüglicher Hochachtung heißt das.
G nicht H.
Aber es ist es ist ja also das ist ein Massenphänomen geworden und das ist es spielt jetzt die Gesellschaft und ich befürchte, dass dieses Thema Impfpflicht
äh so wie ein eingewachsener Zehnnagel noch lange Schmerzen bereitet wird und vielleicht sogar so wie Brexit.
Eine nachhaltige Spaltung der Gesellschaft verursacht. Ähm äh dass man darüber einfach nicht hinwegziehen sehen kann und äh ich habe da schon auch einige Fälle jetzt auch mitbekommen im Familien- und Nahverhältnis und so.
Und und Impfpflicht verstärkt nochmal diese Tendenzen weil's damit halt eben wirklich auch.
Illegal ist, das nicht zu tun und und äh ich äh glaube, dass es viel sinnvoller gewesen wäre mit Anreizen zu arbeiten
ähm und äh Österreich hat sich auch entschieden eine Impflotterie zu machen. Es wurde eine Milliarde Euro dafür zur Verfügung gestellt.
Gewonnen. Strache. Kurz.
Niemand, niemand. Man man ist dann drauf gekommen, dass man äh äh verwaltungstechnisch nicht in der Lage ist, äh das umzusetzen und hat das ganze Projekt wieder.
Ähm ich habe verstehe bis heute nicht wieso. Ich war im Kontakt mit äh dem Kabinett, das da zuständig gewesen wäre und habe ihm gesagt, ihr könnt das so machen. Ihr könnt das so machen. Ihr könnt das so machen. Datenschutz ist kein Problem. Ihr kriegt das hin, aber,
man hat aus irgendeinem Grund dann nicht also,
Das Ding wurde abgeblasen. Keine Ahnung, was jetzt mit dieser Milliarde passiert. Die geht, glaube ich, an die Polizisten und Krankenschwestern.
Und hoffentlich auch die Supermarktverkäuferinnen die in der Krise arbeiten mussten,
Ja, aber so ein positiver Anreiz wird sicherlich besser gewesen als äh äh nur zu strafen, weil äh dann dann igeln sich Leute halt ein in ihren Haltungen und im Grunde bräuchte man, müsste man dann umdenken erzeugen.
Ja und genau da denke ich halt auch oder vor allem für diejenigen, die zweifeln, ne, für diejenigen, die irgendwie denken, ja hör mal, wenn ich Internet aufmache, steht da, da ist ein Chip in dem Dingen äh ich weiß es nicht.
Noch nicht irgendwie die komplette Kurve äh des Wahnsinns genommen haben.
Um die noch zu überzeugen, aber auch darüber haben wir hier schon öfter gesprochen, ähm
Und ich habe heute schon mal so einen Blogpost zugeschrieben. Will keiner mehr hören. Äh jetzt halt automatische Strafen.
Ich würde mal zum nächsten Thema gehen oder gibt's noch mehr Datenskandale.
Nein einen, den wir noch erwähnen müssen, weil der passt auch gut in in die ganze Debatte rund um responsole Disklosure. Ähm.
Also ich habe vorher diesen Datenskandal vom Dezember erwähnt und es gab dann im Jänner auch nochmal einen. Äh und zwar auf der Website Österreich testet AT,
Diese Webseite hat man am Anfang der Pandemie gemacht, um Massentests zu organisieren. Ähm ist unheimlich teuer, hat eine halbe Million in der ähm Erstellung gekostet und kostet im Monat hundertachtundachtzigtausend Euro,
monatliche Kosten.
So eine Website.
Es wird besser. Ähm äh dieser dieser Österreich testet Webseite wurde dann auch verwendet, damit man sich äh für Tests in der Apotheke anmelden kann,
Und irgendwann einmal gab's da so einen äh sehr findigen Webentwickler, der gesehen hat
das ist aber mühsam da immer wenn wenn man in dem einen Tool die Daten in dem es andere Tool übertragen muss. Ich hab da eh diesen API Zugriff, den die mir gegeben haben von Österreich testet. Ich baue hier einfach ein,
für unsere Apotheke. Und dann hatte er hier irgendwie so diese API Zugriffe und hat halt nur ein bissel geschaut und hat gemerkt.
Ich kann nicht nur die Daten von meiner Apotheke einsehen, sondern von allen Apotheken und von allen Testzentren in ganz Österreich.
Und hatte da halt irgendwie äh Zugriff auf auf Millionen Datensätze. Also,
sowohl Corona-Testergebnis der Leute, wie auch ähm Name, Geburtsdatum, Adresse, Sozialversicherungsnummer, Telefonnummer, E-Mail-Adresse, alles was dazugehört. Und.
Als jemand, der nicht das erste Mal Sicherheitslücken findet, hat er sich gedacht, hach, ich weiß, was zu tun ist. Ich schreibe jetzt eine liebe Mail, ich mache denen eine Dokumentation, was ja Fehler ist, die werden das schon reparieren.
Mitnichten. Äh er wurde zuerst mal ignoriert,
dann hat er sich irgendwie ähm an den ORF gewendet, an den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Rundfunk, hat sich gedacht, okay, die helfen mir vielleicht und äh die haben dann auch noch mal nachgefragt beim Gesundheitsministerium, was zuständig ist.
Die Antwort des Gesundheitsministeriums war, ach das ist keine Sicherheitslücke. Der hat das System nur falsch bedient,
die Apotheke schließen wir jetzt von diesem Österreich testet Programm aus.
Was natürlich viel Geld für die Apotheke ist, was sie jetzt verliert. Daraufhin hat sie dem dem Webentwickler gekündigt. Der hat seinen Job verloren. Dafür, dass er die Sicherheitslücke gemeldet hat.
Ja wir haben dann eben gemeinsam mit dem ORF das alles nochmal bewertet und auch nochmal mit der Politik Kontakt aufgenommen zu what the fuck seriously.
Und äh ja man blieb bei dem Standpunkt die ganze Sache, wurde aber medial sehr hochgekocht. Also das war irgendwie ein, zwei Tage, Hauptnachrichten.
Und was bleibt, ist ein ganz äh scharler Beigeschmack. Ähm im vorherigen Themenblock haben wir drüber geredet, abschreckender Effekt für Whistleblower. Das ist so ein abschreckender Effekt für,
Sicherheitsforscherinnen,
weil wenn ich für meinen responseball discloser irgendwie meinen Job verliere, überlege ich mir das zweimal und diese Lücken, das weißt du besser als ich, Linus, äh die kann man auch zu Geld machen.
Und ähm das ist leider wirklich das denkbar schlechteste Verhalten vom Gesundheitsministerium gewesen. Zum Glück hat äh Gykhan S, der der Webentwickler ähm den der das damals herausgefunden hat,
sehr viele Jobangebote bekommen, nachdem das Ganze öffentlich wurde und hat jetzt wieder einen Job.
Aber ähm was bleibt es halt so irgendwie die Frage was müsste so ein Gesundheitsministerium eigentlich tun an so einer Stelle und ich ich glaube halt,
das Schulen vom Personal, damit das weiß, wie es mit solchen Fällen umgehen muss, während das das Mindeste und im Grunde eigentlich auch eine Entschuldigung,
Gesundheitsminister bei Guekan S. Weil ich finde, der hat halt hier wirklich genau den falschen Anreiz gesetzt.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall und es ist ja, es ist ein häufiges Thema hier in der Sendung und es ist äh.
Also genau das dachte ich zwischenzeitlich echt das, was hinter uns hätten, ne. Also nicht nur in Deutschland oder in Österreich, sondern so so ganz.
Grundsätzlich habe ich irgendwann mal gedacht, vielleicht haben wir das hinter uns. Aber ich kenne natürlich auch, jetzt mal so.
Ganz grundsätzlich äh einer äh einer der wichtigen Teile meines Jobs ist ja dafür darüber mir Gedanken zu machen, wie sage ich's ihnen.
Und wie sage ich's ihnen so, dass sie
dass sie eine Motivation haben, das äh Problem zu lösen, dass sie nicht ihr Gesicht verlieren. Also all diese Faktoren, die da so mit reinspielen und ähm.
Das ist so ein bisschen also jetzt wirklich auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, ne? Aber ich sehe echt so eine so eine Mischung.
Oder so eine so eine so eine Parallele zu,
Julian-Hessenthaler ist ein Kokainhändler muss in den Knast und ähm der hat eine Schwachstelle gefunden, den feuern wir, ne. Also so dieses wenn wir die Personen in ausreichend misskredit bringen.
Dann äh kommen wir vielleicht irgendwie besser aus der Nummer raus und äh ist natürlich ein völlig durchschaubares und kontraproduktives Vorgehen.
Was dann dazu führt und übrigens davon habe ich sehr sehr viel in letzter Zeit, äh dass sich Leute äh an mich wenden mit Schwachstellen, die sie irgendwo gefunden haben und sich einfach nicht mehr trauen die zu melden.
Linus äh mach du das mal, hilf mir mal dabei, was sagst du? Äh welcher Anwalt oder sonst was und dann sind streckenweise natürlich jetzt nicht besonders kritische Sachen dabei. Aber einfach nur, dass Leute,
ja Angst haben also dieser dieser Chilling Effekt den sehe ich grade auf jeden Fall in meiner Inbox.
Das ist extrem besorgen zeigen. Das macht uns nicht sicherer, im Gegenteil.
Nee, genau, macht uns nicht sicherer.
Weil die gleichen Leute sich natürlich auch irgendwie nachher denken, okay, wenn ich die Schwachstelle jetzt verkaufe, gut. Man muss selbst so auch sagen, ich meine, diesen,
zu diesem Markt haben die meisten Leute einfach auch keine kein sinnvollen Zugang oder auch vielleicht viele der Sicherheitslücken die sie finden,
sind vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt vermarktbar aber ähm.
Da kriegt man auf jeden Fall größere Sicherheitsversprechen, sagen wir mal, sagen wir's mal so.
Ja, ja. Also bei Gykern ist was auch so, der hat's der Wahrheit gewohnt, dass er dann irgendwie ein nettes Danke bekommt oder manchmal sogar vielleicht eine Tour, dass ich äh was nicht ähm,
ein ein ein sehr bekanntes österreichisches IT-Unternehmen war wirklich dankbar, dem Geschenkskorb gegeben. Äh äh und äh super, dass du das gemacht hast, weißt du? Und das war seine Erwartungshaltung.
Dazu gehört es sich ja auch. Das ist der gute Ton. Aber ja. Ähm ich habe noch ein großes Thema, ähm dass ich.
Gebracht habe und zwar in europäisches.
Genau, das ist jetzt weil wir verlassen Österreich.
Ja, endlich. Ähm ein großes EU-Thema ähm und zwar.
Elektronische Identität. AIDAS ist das Stichwort.
Und äh ich glaube mit mit Flipke war's das hier ein bissl schon über elektronische Identität geredet habt an dem Beispiel,
deutschen Lösung, die da gefloppt ist.
Und ich hab die die spannende Botschaft, dass viele der Dinge vor denen ihr da gewarnt habt.
Auch wirklich kommen werden, weil die stehen in dem Entwurf des EU-Gesetzes, über das ich jetzt mit euch reden werde.
Was ist passiert? Ähm im Juni 20021 hat die EU-Kommission eine Reform der in die Jahre gekommenen AIDAs-Verordnung aus 2014 vorgestellt.
Gesetz, was 2014 müsst ihr nicht kennen, das kennt fast niemand. Der einzige Punkt, wo ihr vielleicht mit dem schon mal in Kontakt gekommen seid, ist, wenn ihr, weiß nicht,
äh in äh Land A lebt und in Land B vielleicht aber ein Einkommen habt, dass ihr versteuern müsst und dann habt ihr sozusagen eure
Identität eurem Pass von Land A und meldet euch mit dem,
dann vielleicht bei der Finanzbehörde von dann B an. Also das war wirklich nur so ein Interoperabel machen von elektronischen Identitätssystemen,
in Österreich wäre das Finanz online zum Beispiel. Also da wo ich meine Steuererklärung abgebe, wenn ich das online tue und ich mich da irgendwie online anmelden kann gibt's manchmal so Boxen, dass man das auch mit den Daten von anderen Ländern tun kann.
Das war alles, was die alte Aiders-Verordnung gemacht hat. Das hat es aber auch gut gemacht. Nur das soll sich jetzt drastisch ändern.
Mit der Reform, die eben im Juni vorgestellt wurde und jetzt langsam in den Verhandlungsprozess reinkommt.
Verhält es sich so, dass es eine Pflicht gibt für alle EU-Mitgliedstaaten, eine sogenannte european Digital Identity Wallet.
Ihren.
Bevölkerung zur Verfügung zu stellen. Ähm diese App äh wahrscheinlich wird es eine Smartphone-App, vielleicht ist es auch eine Hardware-Karte, aber überdenkt man einfach nur an einer App auf eurem Smartphone, weil
es geht sehr stark in diese Richtung. Ähm die wird gratis sein und die wird man verwenden können, um sich zu,
identifizieren, um sich zu authentifizieren, also um sich einzuloggen bei Diensten und um gewisse Eigenschaften über sich äh Dritten glaubhaft zu machen. Wie zum Beispiel ich habe eine Lenkerberechtigung, ich bin ähm,
als 18 oder 21 Jahre und darf hier rein oder Alkohol trinken. Aber auch ich habe diesen und hier in den Coronastatus. Ich habe diesen und jenen Bildungsstatus und so weiter. Das ist,
offen hin, es können beliebige Attribute hier reingegeben werden. Das System muss online und offline kompatibel sein, also sowohl
Webbrowser irgendwie interagieren, wie auch ähm bei einer physischen Kontrolle.
Also schon mal kein Blockchain.
Äh und es
soll eben auch nicht nur gegenüber staatlichen Stellen zum Einsatz kommen, sondern auch gegenüber privaten. Also es sollen auch Firmen ähm in die Lage versetzt werden mit dieser European Digital Entery Wallet, ihre Kunden oder Besucherinnen,
zu identifizieren, zu identifizieren, Eigenschaften von denen abzufragen und.
Ja, das ist so irgendwie das, was es tun soll und dann äh alles, was es falsch macht, ist ähm mit diesem Gesetz gibt es mal eine Verpflichtung für alle Mitgliedsstaaten,
eindeutige, lebenslange Identifikationsnummer für ihre Bevölkerung zur Verfügung zu stellen,
ich glaube in Deutschland ist das illegal aufgrund eines ähm Karlsruher Urteils in einer, ich glaube es war Volkszählung ähm.
Nicht nicht hundertprozentig richtig
also du hast eine lebenslange Identifikationsnummer inzwischen
Das ist diese Steuer-ID und was wir in Deutschland diskutiert haben beim Register-Modernisierungsgesetz ist, äh wollen wir die denn jetzt halt auch als Unique Identify überall einführen und die unterschiedlichen,
Ähm.
Ja die unterschiedlichen Datenbanken quasi durch einen oder durch einen Unique ähm Merchbar machen, ja oder also join bar machen im Prinzip, dass du die dass du die alle zusammenführen kannst.
Der historische Hintergrund dazu, warum man das nicht äh machen möchte, äh den hast du ähm.
Den hast du richtig wiedergegeben und man sieht natürlich auch in den USA.
Warum man das nicht machen möchte, ne? Weil das eben ein Unique Identifier ist, der irgendwo erfasst wird, der auch immer wieder verwendet wird und interessanterweise, also
was du gerade so geschildert hast, wenn ich Capitalities oder
einzeln abgeben kann, ohne den Identify Fire zu geben, dann also da kann man ja ganz grundsätzlich, wenn man es denn möchte,
eine ganze Menge äh ja schöner Systeme mit viel Anonymität drin.
Bauen. Insofern finde ich's umso interessanter, dass sie jetzt sagen, ja hier, man kann, ob man 18 ist oder sonst was spezifisch nachweisen, aber gleichzeitig führen wir mal so einen unique Identifier für die Person lebenslang gebunden ein, weil.
Die moderne Technologie der Zertifizierung genau das eben nicht mehr notwendig macht scheint mir.
Da hast du absolut Recht, dass es ähm äh,
derartige Techniken äh wie wie Zero Knowledge Proofs, ähm es gibt selective disclose, ähm es gibt bei der Interaktion,
ähm der anderen Seite, man nennt die Hiroline Party, also egal ob das ein Start oder eine Firma ist, mit der ich mit meiner App gerade reden will, die Re-Line-Party auf der anderen Seite kriegt nach diesem Gesetz immer eine eindeutige Nummer von mir.
Die auch bei jeder Reline-Party dieselbe ist. Das heißt, die kann mich tracken, auch über verschiedene Interaktionen und Transaktionen hinweg.
Technik hier, wer sich einfach für jede Stelle immer nur einen Identifikator da habe, dann weiß die zwar, mit wem sie gerade spricht und kann mich wiedererkennen, aber zumindest verschiedene Reline-Partys können das nicht.
All das fehlt. All diese Safe Guards sind nicht vorhanden. Auch eine der Save Guards, die wir ähm bei dem grünen Pass auf EU-Ebene letztes Jahr zum Glück reinbekommen haben. Worauf ich sehr stolz bin, diese Unbeobachtbarkeit,
die einzelne Transaktion, dass mein QR-Code gescannt wird von jemandem, eben nicht zentral protokolliert.
Auch das fehlt hier. Es ist sogar explizit vorgeschrieben, dass diese Daten vorhanden sein müssen und dann darf man sie aber nicht mit anderen verbinden. Aber es ist ein beobachtbares System, was hier geplant ist.
Und gerade diese Öffnung gegenüber der Wirtschaft, das ist wirklich,
Ein ganz gefährlicher Dammbruch, weil ich habe das an einigen Stellen miterlebt, wie massiv das Industrieinteresse an solchen Systemen ist. Und das beginnt,
bei Banken, die ihre rechtlichen neue Vorgaben haben und das geht.
Weiter über den gesamten E-Commerce, wo du natürlich wissen willst, wer ist dein Kunde, ach ich hätte gerne irgendwie kryptografisch bestätigt, dass das deine Adresse ist, bevor ich da jetzt was hinliefere,
ähm oder den Rechnungsanschrift.
Bis hin eben zu Medien, die dieseartige Systeme verwenden wollen für das Abschließen von Operoments oder das Ausstellen von personalisierter Verb.
Projekte gab's in der Vergangenheit schon und die sind halt immer an der technischen Machbarkeit gescheitert.
Äh nicht nur werden die Kosten der Identifikation, der Identifikation mit dem System 0 sein. Es wird auch wirklich ganz einfach zu bedienen sein, genauso wie eben der der grüne Pass dieses covid-Zertifikat,
Du holst halt einfach nur kurz dein Handy raus.
Und ja es ist ist auch so, dass diese dieser diese Verordnung, also das ist ein EU-Gesetz, das direkt gelten wird in allen 27 EU-Staaten.
28 Stellen hat, wo die Kommission die EU-Kommission sich selber die Möglichkeit gibt, ähm mittels Verordnung erst Dinge zu regeln,
also Verordnungsermächtigungen, mit denen ist das ganze Gesetz gespickt, auch an zentralen Stellen,
wo einfach der Gesetzestext äh dir gar nicht wirklich erzählt, wie's wirklich laufen wird, weil erst nachdem das Gesetz beschlossen ist, sechs Monate später muss die Kommission dieser Delegated oder Implementing-Acts machen.
Sich natürlich jederzeit ändern können,
Wie das Ganze technisch implementiert werden soll, ähm war lange in Verhandlung. Das da hätte eine Toolbox schon im Dezember veröffentlicht werden sollen,
ist jetzt äh gestern am 22. Februar veröffentlicht worden, zumindest die Outline dieser Toolbox,
verlinken wir auch, wer sich da mal rein tigern will. Da hat man eben auch ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren und einen technischen Standard parallel laufen.
Ja, das Ganze ist jetzt eben in den Ausschüssen im Europaparlament. Ich habe das Mandat von,
eben den Sachverband dazu zu vertreten, war im Industrieausschuss schon und auch im Bürgerrechtsausschuss.
Ersteres Hering war auch auch öffentlich und ähm ja im Moment beginnt halt das Klinkenputzen und dass irgendwie Leute,
zu sensibilisieren für dieses Thema. Wenn wir wenn das so kommt, dann haben wir eine eine wirklich generelle Infrastruktur, die Identifikation.
Zu einem alltäglichen Ding machen, dass dass wir nicht mehr wegbekommen und wer jetzt glaubt, das wird doch eh nur ein Rohrkapierer.
Dieses System wird natürlich verpflichtend für alle E-Government-Anwendungen, also jedes Mal, wenn der Staat mich identifizieren will, muss er das verwenden.
Und die großen Internetplattformen werden dazu verpflichtet dieses System zu verwenden,
Jan Penffert von Edry hat ja ähm mal über den Digital Services Act gesprochen. Da gibt's ja die Definition der Online-Plattforms derer bedient man sich in diesem Gesetz und dieser großen Internetplattformen,
die müssen dieses System einsetzen, um ihre ähm User, ihren Usern den Login zu ermöglichen.
Äh damit ist natürlich auch so diese Tracking-ID, die uns uns dann unser ganzes Leben lang verfolgt, äh sofort bei Facebook und Google.
Kleinere Firmen können wiederum per per Verordnung, bei delegated Act von der Kommission verpflichtet werden, diese European Digital Identity Volley zu verwenden.
Und ja, das ist noch nicht alles. Es gibt auch noch äh den schönen Artikel 45. Der schreibt vor, dass alle Webbrowser.
Zertifikate von EU-Mitgliedsstaaten in ihrer äh Listen aufnehmen müssen. Das heißt in die Trust Stores in die Liste an Zertifikaten die für jede Website dieser Welt ausstellen können und du bist echt.
Wollen alle 27 EU-Länder rein, was äh äh hatten wir,
hat Kasachstan äh probiert und ist damit gescheitert, weil die Browser sagen, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Ihr wollt nur überwachen. Machen wir nicht,
und jetzt steht das hier drinnen und ist natürlich genauso auch wieder wahnsinnig gefährlich für das Sicherheitsmodell, das World.
Ich glaube, bei Kasachstan ist der Fall nicht nur also,
bei denen war der Punkt, die kam nicht rein, weil sie vor allem auch schon vorher überwacht haben, wenn mich meine äh Erinnerung nicht täuscht, ne. Also eine CA, die ihre Vertrauenswürdigkeit
bewiesenermaßen nicht erfüllt, die ist natürlich auch rucki zucki wieder raus, aber.
Ich so, oh wie klar, wir wir nehmen jetzt mal den legislativen Weg, um uns zum Vertrauensanker der IT zu machen. Oh, oh, oh, ne. Das ist also.
Sehr, sehr, sehr äh gefährliche Angelegenheit. Ist genauso keine tolle Angelegenheit, wenn wenn das zu einem,
Oligopol, der äh Trust Anbieter wird, ja, wie es ja zum Glück äh Let's and Gryp dann irgendwann auch sehr stark und sehr erfolgreich angegriffen hat, aber ah das sind alles so so.
So Ideen, ne? Und ich ich erkenne wirklich, also ich schaue mir ja so ein bisschen den Markt an.
Also Identity ist schon seit langer Zeit
so das Ding, wo alle irgendwie draufstehen, ne? Irgendwie so gesehen, so aha ja Identity, hier wir haben die Innenminister, die wollen Führerschein, wir haben die Banken, die wollen ähm
da irgendwie mit dran und irgendwie wäre doch alles voll geil mit Identity und dann kommen die
Blockchain Schwachmaten und sagen, na Identity, das ist ja eigentlich nur ein NFT und dann hast du irgendwelche Blockchain-basierten äh ID-Provider, die auf einmal über mehrere Länder,
Planeten expandieren ohne nennenswerte Kunden.
Weil der einfach ordentlich VC hinter ist, ne, also Venture Capital, wo im Prinzip gesagt wird, komm wir bauen, wir müssen dieses Unternehmen jetzt bauen, weil wir wissen, dass der ähm,
der Bedarf halt auch dann irgendwann von den Regierungen definiert wird. Da hast du wirklich äh.
Es ist so so,
so durchschaubar, ja und das ist ja auch genau das Abwasser in das jetzt die Luca App äh weiterschwimmt äh zu sagen ah super, wir sind verbreitet jetzt machen wir hier irgendwie Identity und so ein Kram ne und du denkst dir wirklich so.
Was erlaube Staat? Ja, was was erlaube.
EU auch also auch diese diese hoheitliche Aufgabe so so bekloppt dann aus der Hand zu geben.
Und damit so so unvorsichtig umzugehen in Zeiten, wo wirklich muss man auch sagen, es schöne
kryptografische Lösungen dafür seit 20 Jahren gibt. Und ähm die jetzt um die kryptografischen Entwicklungen der letzten 5 und zehn Jahre ergänzt, dann so wirklich eigentlich coolen Shit ermöglichen würden,
Und wieder mal das nicht mitzunehmen.
Es ist wirklich ähm schmerzhaft und da da natürlich hat man große Sorge, wenn.
Jetzt kommt solche mal wieder diese gefährliche äh Brüssel Perspektive Brüssel Vorteil es wird irgendwie nicht äh unter Druck der Tagespolitik irgendwie verhandelt und die,
dort Abgeordneten haben irgendwie mehr mehr Freiheit äh von Fraktionszwang und sonstigem. Können irgendwie so ein bisschen von der Tagespolitik entkoppelt arbeiten. Aber regelmäßig fände der lange genug nicht hinguckst, kommt halt irgend so ein Axel Voss raus und und verkündet.
Was Neues und diese Weltfremdheit, die macht einem dann natürlich doch schon ein bisschen Sorge.
So so war's auch irgendwie so bei diesem Gesetz. Also das kam raus im Juni und ich wurde von Political Europe gefragt, weil irgendwie bei Idra war klar, ich bin der Einzige, der ein Air die arbeitet. Deswegen äh konnte ich gleich am Anfang meine Stellungnahme abgeben.
Political Europe ist halt äh das, was alle lesen in der Brüsseler Babel.
Ich hatte innerhalb von zwei Tagen ein Meeting request von äh äh einer sehr sehr hohen äh Kommissionsbeamtin, wo man normalerweise.
Egal wie sehr man sich anstrengt, man kriegt kein Meeting und.
Für die war das so because we expected praise from the privacy Community. Die haben ernsthaft gedacht, die kriegen hier ein ein lautes Klatschen, weil wir wollen doch hier irgendwie eine Alternative zur Login wo Facebook.
Ist das nicht eine gute Sache, dass es da irgendwie eine kritische Diskussion gibt und dass ähm diese diese ähm Blockchain-Button nicht hier irgendwie ein Alleinvertretungsanspruch haben.
Das war denen nicht bewusst,
die Pfarrabhängigkeit ist enorm. Also wir verlinken auch äh ähm da gibt es Ausschreibungen in der Höhe von 53 Millionen für elektronische Identität und Blockchain.
Also zu einem Thema, wo sich der der Gesetzestext von dem, was erlaubt ist, jetzt dann noch massiv ändern wird,
gibt jetzt schon im Vorfeld irgendwie das Geld aus äh an an anstatt irgendwie zuerst mal die Save Guards festzulegen demokratisch äh wieso Systeme ausschauen sollen, bevor wir sie verwenden wollen und.
Es geht alles in eine in eine komische Richtung und auch diese Festlegung auf Smartphones, die hier passiert ist. Also das das steht nicht im Gesetz drinnen, aber wenn man,
zwischen den Zeilenliest ist es sehr klar, dass es nur das sein kann an Smartphone Security ist natürlich auch 1001 und dann ein altes N-Wort, das kann das Sicherheitsamt jetzt mehr bekommt.
Es ist äh einfach äh viel anfälliger für Identitätsdiebstahl. Ähm wenn man da ins Telefon reinkommt, dann hat man alles, um sich auszuweisen für die Person und rechtsgültig zu unterschreiben.
Und äh das das ist natürlich dann auch so in in Sachen Digital Devite ein Problem,
weil äh das was wir mit Dark Patdance heute schon sehen, wo Leuten ein Konzent abgerungen wird, der wirklich definitiv nicht informiert war. Die wussten gar nicht, äh was sie da zugestimmt haben.
Das wird natürlich nochmal um einiges brenzliger äh mit solchen Systemen. Wo ich halt wirklich nur die Keys von diesem Wallet brauche, um alles damit zu machen.
Das ist alles nicht mit bedacht, dass das versucht irgendwie eine eierlegende Wollmilchsau zu sein, die die Industrie glücklich macht,
den den Staaten bei ihren leidigen E-Government Use Cases, die die Pandemie jetzt halt irgendwie deutlich gemacht hat, zu helfen und.
Was eigentlich ein kluges System, wäre das vor allem wirklich eine eine europäische Antwort auf diese Fragestellung wäre. Ähm die Frage haben Sie sich, glaube ich, ernsthaft noch nicht gestellt,
Aber die werden wir hoffentlich jetzt im im im parlamentarischen Prozess klären.
Ursprünglich wollten sie das in in Lichtgeschwindigkeit durchboxen, also wirklich so wir stellen das im Juni zwanzig einundzwanzig vor, im Juni zwanzigzweiundzwanzig soll's verabschiedet werden. Das ist mal gestorben,
Also die die aktuelle Zeit lang ist, dass zum Beispiel der Bürgerrechtsausschuss erst Mitte Mai,
einen Bericht vorlegen wird über dann erst den dann erst abgestimmt wird im Herbst und wir werden wahrscheinlich erst Ende dieses Jahres in in die Trilog-Verhandlungen gehen wo Mitgliedsstaaten, Parlament und Kommission,
sich zusammensetzen mit ihren Positionen. Also wenigstens der Druck ist draußen, sodass man jetzt mal in Ruhe wieder über das Thema reden kann, aber man sollte dieses Jahr jetzt nutzen,
weil jetzt werden die die Grundregeln, die die Grundregeln für elektronische Identität geschrieben.
Dieses Gesetz ist eine Vollharmonisierung, da bleibt auch kein nationaler äh äh kein nationaler Spielraum mehr übrig, Dinge anders zu machen, sondern es wird dann eine european Digital Identity Wallet geben,
interoperabel ist zwischen allen Ländern. Und ähm deswegen, wer sich mal für dieses Thema interessiert, ähm.
Gibt doch eine Mitmach-Seite bei uns. Wer sich da irgendwie ehrenamtlich beteiligen will, aber für uns wird es, also für für mich persönlich auf jeden Fall ein ein ein sehr ähm starker Fokus sein von meiner Arbeit, weil ich finde einfach.
Das ist wahnsinnig wichtig und wenn wir das hier verkacken, dann verkacken wir viele.
Ähm es erinnert mich an das, was wir hier in der Sendung auch schon oft gesagt haben. Also wenn du ein eine einfachere Anwendung von Ausweis.
Führt halt zu einer häufigeren Nutzung und das also Ausweisung ist in der Regel in Situationen die gegen dich sind.
Die äh ist wirklich ne also dass du deinen Ausweis zeigst, ist selten,
wirklich selten etwas, das das ernsthaft in deinem Interesse ist, ne. Ähm eine Identification ist am Ende gegen dich, weil sie dir,
eben die die,
anonyme Nutzung gibt's pseudonyme Nutzung versagt, weil sie deine Möglichkeiten, was weiß ich, eine Weitergabe äh oder sonstigen,
irgendwie einschränkt und das allgegenwärtig zu machen ist etwas, was man einfach auch nicht möchte.
Ja, also es gibt es gibt einen Vorschlag von uns eben mit einer Antidiskriminierungsregel ähm das Ganze ein bissel zu entschärfen, indem man sagt, es darf
zumindest beim Zugang zu staatlichen Leistungen besser noch bei Zugang zu privatwirtschaftlichen Gütern und Dienstleistungen keine Unterscheidung gemacht werden, ob jetzt jemand diese
Wallet-App hat oder nicht. Das wäre vor allem auch ähm für die Generation an Menschen, die einfach kein Smartphone haben,
oder die die die sich auch einfach ähm mit der Technik nicht beschäftigen wollen, ähm einen Schutz
weil wir sehen heute schon, dass zum Beispiel ähm
in Wien, da wo ich lebe, äh wenn man da mit dem Staat interagiert und gewisse Behördenwege macht und man hat keine elektronische Identität, ja dann sind die Dinger halt 30 Prozent teurer.
Also gerade jene, die sich vielleicht auch kein Smartphone leisten können, haben wir jetzt nochmal doppelt benachteiligt bei allgegenwärtigen Dingen,
Also so eine Antidiskriminierungsrede, dass man einfach eben nicht das das das Vorhandensein von dieser Technik zur Voraussetzung macht.
Oder zum Unterscheidungskriterium das wär zumindest für die nächsten Jahrzehnte glaube ich ganz essentiell vielleicht auch bis wir irgendwie besser verstanden haben was diese Technik da mit uns macht.
Aber gut, ich habe ja noch gute Nachrichten mitgebracht.
Ähm äh und und einfach nur so der Vollständigkeitshalber Netzertralität, weil das ja auch lange mein ähm,
Lieblingsthema war da gab es gute Nachrichten durch den EuGH, die habt ihr glaube ich auch oder haben wir hier in der Sendung schon mal kurz erwähnt, dass der EuGH Zero-Rating verboten hat und zwar auf ganzer Linie.
Da gibt es jetzt auch schon so erste Indikationen, in welche Richtung die Reform gehen wird.
Sehr wahrscheinlich wird ähm und Vodafone Past, die Produkte, die in Deutschland sehr pole populär sind und auch zum Beispiel Freestream von Telekom Austria in Österreich. Die werden alle verboten werden.
Und hier gibt's jetzt eine wichtige Durchsage ähm für alle Kunden dieser Produkte,
ihr solltet drauf schauen, dass ihr vielleicht mehr Datenvolumen angeboten bekommt von eurem Netzbetreiber,
weil jetzt durch das Wegfallen des Zero-Ratings natürlich der Tarif den ihr habt weniger attraktiv werdet. Ihr könnt dann einfach weniger YouTube oder äh Vimeo nutzen als vorher,
äh wer so ein ähm äh zusätzliches Datenvolumen nicht bekommt, der sollte eigentlich ein Sonderkündigungsrecht bekommen.
Das ist zumindest so die Debatte, in die es jetzt gerade geht. Ich war dabei ein paar Anhörungen dabei, der Bundesnetzagentur.
Und äh äh die Telekom-Industrie ist dann noch in absoluter Realitätsverweigerung.
Und glaubt hier irgendwie dem EuGH abzusprechen, dass er der weiß ja gar nicht, was er tut und das kann man ja nicht ernst nehmen und äh.
Aber zum Glück jetzt sehr bestimmt von der Bundesnetzagentur und anderen Regulierungsbehörden so Reusper, das ist das Höchstgericht, das haben sie jetzt nicht gesagt.
Und die lernen halt jetzt auch, dass wenn der EuGH was entscheidet, dann ist es entschieden.
Und äh das äh wird eh noch der Reformprozess bei Barrec bei dem Zusammenschluss der Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden.
Noch äh dauern. Wir haben wahrscheinlich im März einen ersten von den neuen Regeln.
Konstruktiert werden und im Juni oder September werden die beschlossen sein. Ähm und äh spätestens dann erwarte ich mir auch ähm,
diese Entscheidungen, die jetzt rechtlich glasklar sind, dass diese Produkte keinen Platz mehr in Europa haben und ähnlich wie in Indien Zerorating einfach verboten gehört, sondern alle Bits sind gleich, egal ob man schneller oder langsamer macht oder billiger oder teurer,
keine Unterscheidung im Netz durch den Netzbetreiber,
Und äh das dürfte jetzt auch ähm hoffentlich ist eigentlich alles bei nett zur Qualität erledigt. Da können wir das Thema abhacken. Das war immer mein Ziel.
Die Konsequenz für die Netzbetreiber ist natürlich ähm mehr Datenvolumen dann bereit,
zu stellen, was sie letztendlich nichts kosten sollte, weil sie dieses Datenvolumen ja trotzdem gerade verbrauchen.
Ja? Also äh um das nur nochmal eins zu sortieren. Und wenn du mit so einem Netzbetreiber sprichst, ich habe ja mit denen zu tun, äh dann,
hörst du so etwas wie dass sie sagen na ja okay pass auf. Wir haben dieses Netz, stimmt.
Das Netz äh hat bestimmte Kosten, sie sind mehr oder weniger fix. Ja und wir haben natürlich einerseits das Ziel, möglichst viele Kunden zu haben.
Und äh da damit geht das Ziel niedriger. Einstiegstarifverein her und die sagen im Prinzip ähm also die geben freimütig zu, dass der Einzelne,
Anschluss quasi jetzt nicht in ihren Kosten nennenswert variiert.
Nur weil er ein paar Gigabyte mehr verbraucht oder nicht.
Ne und das sie natürlich dann sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir eine Preisdifferenzierung, wir wollen einerseits natürlich niedrige Einstiegsangebote haben, um von vielen Leuten,
Viele Subscriber zu haben ähm und wir möchten aber natürlich andererseits dann irgendwie denen, die das mehr nutzen, da denen wir halt auch mehr Geld weg
ja und wenn die wenn sie so argumentieren.
Klingt das ja erstmal gar nicht blöd. Jetzt gehen Sie aber hin und sagen ausgerechnet schon in den niedrigen Tarifen. Machen Sie in den Zero-Rating für die ähm.
Äh für die Volumenhungrigendienste, ja fürn ich
mich jetzt mit den Tarifen gerade nicht aus, aber irgendwie finde Zwanni hast du glaube ich schon irgendwie so einen Tarif mit Stream on oder so, ne und dann hast du halt ein paar Gig oder oder vielleicht auch wahrscheinlich nur ein halbes Kick. Volumen,
für den Teil, der nicht durch irgendwie eine Twitter, Facebook, äh Spotify und Netflix Flatrate,
ist, ja und dann fragst du dich natürlich, ja gut, die diese Leute, denen ihr offiziell fünfhundert Gig verkauft, die ballern euch doch trotzdem irgendwie zehn, fuffzehn, zwanzig durch die Leitung.
Aber wie gesagt, die Argumentation von den Netzbetreibern ist eben zu sagen, okay, den Power-Usern, den die brauchen ja offenbar mehr, also mit dieser künstlichen Verknappung schaffen wir irgendeine Form der,
Leistungsgerechtigkeit. Letztendlich denke ich die die sinnvolle Reaktion kann eigentlich nur sein, dass sie jetzt hingehen und sagen okay was ballern denn die Leute so über ihr Stream on?
Nehmen wir jetzt jeden Vertrag, den es schon gibt und knallen da so viel Datenvolumen drauf und das ist eben eine Flatrate und es wird einfach auch keinen Unterschied für die machen.
In den tatsächlichen Kosten. Ja, also die können sehr kostenneutral von diesem,
Angebot Abstand nehmen. Äh sie stellen aber natürlich fest, dass das in der.
Also im im in der in dem wie heißt das denn Competition in dem Wettkampf oder in den Wettbewerb genau,
Wettbewerb mit den ähm anderen natürlich sehr wohl so ein schönes Ding ist zu sagen pass auf, das kriegst du alles umsonst, was was ja nicht stimmt. Das hat sie ja trotzdem, das ist ja eingepreist. Also natürlich kannst du.
Die gleiche Leistung bekommen. Ähm,
dann irgendwie so eine so eine richtige Flatrate kostet glaube ich bei der Telekom immer noch irgendwie annähernd oder um die einhundert Euro und jede weitere SIM-Karte 25. Das sind natürlich utopische ähm.
Utopische Tarife.
Ich zahle 20 Euro für eine 5G-Flattrade in Österreich.
Ich muss jetzt gucken, was ich für die, also ich habe ich kenne diese Telekomtarife, ich setze mich damit äh Telekom.
Aber Linus, die sparen sich sogar noch Geld, wenn dieses Stream-on wegfällt
Weil da ist es nämlich so, man muss man muss da wirklich ja mit den Diensten kommunizieren, wie identifizieren wir jetzt euren Datenverkehr? Da müssen wir unter Laborbedingungen sicherstellen, dass das auch funktioniert. Wir müssen Verträge aufsetzen. All das fällt weg,
Es ist halt einfach wieder Wasser. Es ist einfach nur Bits und man hat macht damit auch den Weg frei für wie du sagst Mehrwettbewerb,
was in Deutschland fehlt, sind virtuelle Netzbetreiber. Dass man einfach sagt okay, diese Netze in Deutschland, wir haben viel zu wenig Wettbewerb, es gibt jetzt einfach die die Verpflichtung, da mal 30 Prozent der Netzkapazitäten,
für virtuelle Anbieter zur Verfügung zu stellen, dann hast du wieder ordentlichen Wettbewerb mit schön, hart regulierten Vorleistungsentgelten,
das Bit wirklich nur das kostet, was es kostet und die ganzen fetten Margens und Managergehälter daraus gerechnet sind. Und dann hast du einfach wieder so was Netz kostet in den reinen Bestehungskosten.
Ähm das verbunden mit ach ihr wollt staatliche Leistungen haben, okay gut, hier ist unser Plan, wie ihr euer Netz ausbauen sollt,
Wir haben euch nämlich, wir haben uns nämlich die Daten von euch geholt, wie das Netz wirklich ist.
Nicht mühsam über User die erst messen, sondern nein euer intern ja vorhandenen Daten über eure Netzkapazitäten. Also gerade in Deutschland im Telekombereich, das ist ja ein seit Jahrzehnten anhaltendes Marktversagen,
man müsste da wirklich was man da tun muss, sieht man ihnen fast jeden anderen EU-Land. Also nur Portugal ist ähnlich schlecht aufgestellt wie Deutschland. Wenn's um Mobilfunk.
Und es ist bekannt, was man tun müsste.
Hast du aber wenigstens Glasfaser?
Genau äh und,
Ja, also ich hoffe, dass das das hilft irgendwie so den Charakter von von Internetzugang. Das ist wie Wasser. Tim ist du heute nicht da, aber da hat er recht. Das ist so.
War immer sein Spruch äh äh ähm scheiße Abfallinternet. Es ist es gehört halt zu jedem Haushalt dazu, damit du irgendwie dein Haus hinstellst, gehört da halt auch gute Netzanbindung rein und.
Ja äh vielleicht erkennt man dann eher so, es ist wie Wasser. Netz ist halt einfach etwas, das braucht man als Zugang gleichberechtigt für alle und die Sache ist gut.
Ja, aber schau mal.
Also ich habe jetzt hier diese Telekom-Seite auf, ne? Das wird schon sehr lustige Tarife. Du wirst lachen. Ähm also ich ich habe jetzt hier die Magenta-Mobiltarife. Sechs Gig, vierzig Euro.
Zwölf Gig, fünfzig.
Vierundzwanzig Gig sechzig. Ne? Jetzt schaust du natürlich und denkst dir so, boah, guck mal, ähm.
Hier vierfache Leistung,
für anderthalbfachen Preis, ne? Ist eigentlich äh ist eigentlich Spitze. Entsprechend steht da auch Empfehlung dran.
Dann steht da äh Magenta-Mobil XL unbegrenzt äh äh fünfundachtzig Euro. Entschuldigung, ich hatte der war früher mal irgendwo bei hundert,
aber der kostet jetzt, wenn du sagst, da brauchst du doch eine eine Sim für deine Apple Watch, ne und für dein iPad. Da musst du vor viel mehr zahlen, weil eine weitere SIM kostet 25 Euro. Ähm.
Du siehst aber natürlich, dass sie hier ein ähm einen Preisgestaltungsmodell machen. Ähm.
Das Argument stimmt natürlich. Wenn du jetzt sagst, du nimmst den Sechs-Gig-Vertrag und Facebook, Twitter, Netflix und Spotify und wie sie alle heißen, sind mit drin.
Dann wird es schwer, die restlichen sechs Gig noch zu verballern.
Es sei denn, du du sitzt irgendwo, du bist irgendwann mal ein Tag unterwegs und äh äh wagst es zu machen.
Es äh ja es sei denn, du hast irgendwie E-Learning oder eine Long-Distance-Beziehung oder musst vielleicht von zu Hause aus arbeiten und hast Arbeitsvideokonferenzen.
Oder du hast Podcasts, abonniert die nicht über fucking Spotify gehen, sondern über RS,
wie es einfach in in echten Internet äh Umgebungen ist, dann hast du natürlich die sechs Gig relativ schnell weg. Wir müssen aber ja auch um Power-User dann gepasst werden nicht in die Geschäftsmodelle. Da musst du halt mehr zahlen. Zehn Euro, zwanzig Euro mehr zahlen.
Letztendlich ähm,
Es ich habe das hier in dieser Sendung schon öfter zitiert und ähm ich weiß auch, dass derjenige, von dem ich diesen Spruch habe, ein äh fleißiger Hörer der Sendung ist, er sei da hiermit äh gegrüßt.
Er hat immer gesagt, telefonieren ist so teuer, weil billing so teuer ist. Also die Infrastrukturen zu bauen ähm,
die Einzelabrechnung für die Telefonate zu machen. Die Infrastruktur dafür zu bauen, irgendwelche Leute nach sechs, zwölf oder vierundzwanzig zu diskriminieren, aber nur, wenn die nicht unter Stream on sind und so weiter. Das sind
Projekte, die kosten unglaublich viel und also Mobilfunknetze funktionieren auch ohne, dass man Rechnungen schreibt,
Also alles, was du da oben und die funktioniert sogar besser, ohne dass man Rechnungen schreibt.
Linus, Linus, aber das ist ja das, das ist ja das Schöne bei einem virtuellen Netzwerkbetreiber.
Diese Hypothese kannst du testen, wenn du sagst, okay, dann mache die jetzt halt irgendwie zehn Firmen auf diesem Netz, ihr eigenes Buling, ihrer eigenen Kundensysteme. Und ich sagte, in der Effektivität ist das billiger.
Natürlich die MVs sind ja auch alle billiger. Also die die NWNOs machen dir ja die billigeren Tarife. Ja? Äh also,
kannst du dir anschauen. Was hast du hier in Deutschland? Drillisch
ähm eins und eins, Leberer und Aldi-Talk, Lidl äh Lidl, warte, da gibt's ja alles, ne? Und die haben ja die, die zeigen dir ja, wie man dieses Netz
von denen mietet,
Ja und ähm profitabel zu sehr viel günstigeren ähm Tarifen anbietet. Und natürlich brauchen wir eigentlich eine Welt, in der man sagt, okay gut, dann kostet das jetzt vierzig und dann könnt ihr alle machen, was ihr wollt,
aber dieser Preisdifferenzierung eben doch den den einen Anreiz zu bieten, vielleicht doch mehr zu zahlen,
eben bei 4undzwanzig Gig und 60 Euro zu empfehlen. Äh dass das lenkt, diese Preisgestaltungsmodelle und das sind am Ende ähm und ich glaube, da sind wir uns beide einig, darauf wollte ich auch hinaus eben Idee also.
Das was da lenkt ist die Idee psychologischer Anreize mehr zu bezahlen.
Unbedingt, äh dass es hier irgendeine Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
gäbe, dass du mehr bekommst für dein Geld oder dass du mehr zahlen musst, weil du mehr kostest oder so. Äh bei dieser Unterscheidung sechs zwölf vierundzwanzig Gig und unbegrenzt,
des des teuerste ist immer noch die Infrastruktur zu bauen, das zu unterscheiden und nicht, dass du wirklich jetzt mal einen Gegen mehr verwendet hast.
Absolut, also die die die ähm wirklichen variablen Kosten, das ist interconnect, das ist Strom, das ist fast nix. Aber eben äh das Ding hinzustellen.
Und und die haben Sie ja offenbar mit Ihrem Stream und jetzt ohnehin, ja? Das ist ja der Punkt. Die haben Sie ja gerade. Sie sagen ja hier, Stream on, alles ist gar kein Problem.
Ah hör mal auf. Gut Thomas es ist trotzdem eine gute Nachricht ähm im März gibt's den Draft im Juni, September gibt's den Beschluss und dann ist hier zappenduster.
Dann gibt's äh Flatrate für alle.
Für alle, so schaut's aus, Datenkommunismus.
Bin ich mal gespannt. Also ich ich bin ich äh.
Bin wirklich gespannt, wie sich die Mobilfunknetze dann verhalten. Ja, also ähm ob die da nicht irgendwie.
Also ich ich glaube, dass bei denen auch der Plan auf dem hm auf dem Tisch liegt, ähm richtig zum Sturm zu blasen gegen die.
Gegen die EU, ja oder gegen die Bereck und zu sagen hier,
wisst ihr noch, als ihr damals gehüpft seid, Axel Voss, diese äh dass ihr jetzt nur noch sechs Gig habt oder so was, das äh habt ihr,
den gleichen Schwachmarken zu verdanken. Macht mal richtig Musik, ne. Also ich könnte mir echt vorstellen, dass sie da nochmal ihre Marktmacht ausnutzt, um um sich gegen die Regulierung,
zu wehren,
Ich bin wirklich äußerst gespannt, weil bei einigen Dingen bin ich ja wirklich selber gespannt und frage mich, was machen die? Wie werden die agieren oder was was haben die in der Hinterhand für eine neue Cash Cow oder so? Der wird auf jeden Fall noch einiges kommen.
Ich werde ein Auge drauf haben. Ähm wir haben noch ein ein äh deutsches Thema von dir.
Ja, nicht mein Thema, sondern von Andre, äh André Meister, der auch aus unserem Team ist und aber fest angestellt und dauerhaft bei Netzpolitik ORG und der hat,
Jahre natürlich mal wieder äh seiner seiner Lebenszeit damit verbracht. Ähm sich dem Erzes äh äh anzunähern und zwar ist Erzes,
vom Bundeskriminalamt selbst gebastelte Staatstrojaner. Hm.
Der war äh das ist das Remote Commuication Interception Software. Ähm also ein.
Quellen TKÜ System, das äh.
Digitale Telefonie abhören soll, ja? Ähm in der ersten Version davon,
Die war 2016 fertig, konnte man also Skype auf Windows abhören und die zweite Version seit 20018 soll auch mobile Geräte wie Smartphones äh.
In irgendeiner Form abholen können. Dazu gibt es eine Art Pflichtenheft und diesen,
Trojaner also das Pflichtenheft soll auch die gesetzlichen Vorgaben eben sicherstellen und dann haben sie diesen Trojaner vom Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik und der,
Firma TÜV-Informationstechnik prüfen lassen.
Und auch äh dann eben die Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz. Ja das das BSI so etwas prüfen muss, äh haben wir ja auch äh öfter besprochen. Ist natürlich nicht äh ähm vertrauensfördernd
wenn das äh eigentlich der Sicherheit der Bürgerinnen,
verpflichtete BSI hier eine Abhörtechnik äh prüfen soll und ja jetzt hat äh eben Andre eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage auf frag den Staat,
gestellt und hat dann äh nach langer, nach langem Hin und Her ähm zwanzig2zwanzig einen diesen,
diesen Bericht bekommen, ja? Und das das sind wir reden hier von einem Code Review. Jetzt müssen wir vielleicht nochmal diese Vorgeschichte ein bisschen wieder geben. Zweitausendelf, also vor ziemlich genau.
Oder vor vor zehneinhalb Jahren, zehn Jahren ungefähr hatte der Chaos-Computer-Club
seine den Digitaskrojaner in die Finger bekommen. Also den Staatstrojaner, der in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland eben in,
Ermittlungsverfahren eingesetzt wurde, eine auseinandergenommen, eine Reihe katastrophaler Schwachstellen festgestellt, die sich unter anderem dazu eigneten.
Ähm Dateien, also potenziell auch äh kompromittierendes Material auf dem Zielsystem unterzubringen. Ähm und
eine Reihe anderer ähm Schwachstellen, die auch dazu führten, dass dieses System eben relativ schnell erkannt wurde, als nicht den gesetzlichen Vorgaben entsprechend.
Das hat in Deutschland einen relativ großen Skandal ausgelöst ähm der,
damit mündete, dass dieses System nicht mehr einsetzbar war und dass Deutschland längere Zeit einen solchen Staat zuhören nicht hatte. Die Perspektive des CCC nach wie vor auch meine ist,
sich eigentlich so ein, dass was ein Quellen-TKÜ-Staatstrojaner sein soll, äh ist eine juristische Fiktion, die sich technisch nicht wirklich umsetzen lässt ähm und dann ist ein ist natürlich sehr gespannt, wenn das BKA sagt, dann machen wir jetzt selber.
Gleichzeitig ähm ähm.
Sind sie natürlich mit irgendwelchen anderen Unternehmen natürlich auch in Diskussionen. Wir wissen all das größtenteils ehrlich gesagt einfach nur durch die Forschung äh von André Meister die Investigativen Untersuchungen in diesem Bereich.
Jetzt also mit äh Finn Fischer haben Sie Verträge mit NSO Pegasus hatten Sie lange Zeit äh gravierende,
rechtliche Bedenken und jetzt bedeutet das natürlich, wie wichtig das ist, dieses remote,
äh auseinanderzunehmen und jetzt kriegen Kit der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte dahin, beziehungsweise es beginnt ja ähm,
lange Zeit vorher durch mit der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Andrea Voßhoff,
dann äh gibt es einen neue neues Review später in der Amtszeit von Ulrich Kälber und dann eben ein Bericht und da gibt es eine,
Eine Sache, die wollte ich in dem Moment, wo ich sie gesehen habe, äh unmittelbar als Aufkleber haben.
Nämlich also ist ein zehnseitiger Bericht, zehn Seiten, mehr nicht äh für ein Code-Review,
ähm dann dieser wunderschöne Teil da drin, die Software ist geeignet und dann kommen irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, acht bis neun Zeilen schwarzer Block.
Die Software ist in der Lage riesiger schwarzer Block, noch ein riesiger schwarzer Block und dann die Software ist ein,
Die Software ist geeignet, die Software ist in die Lage und die Software ist ein und was hier geschwärzt wurde ist letztendlich sowas wie eine dreiviertel DIN A4 Seite.
Wunderschöne Schwerzung. Also das Ding, als ich das gesehen habe, habe ich sofort gesagt, das ist das ist T-Shirt würdig, das ist plakatwürdig. Das ist aufkleberwürdig. Das ist Kunst, das ist äh Spitze, ja.
Gleichzeitig natürlich ein zehnseitiger zehnseitiger Bericht mit einem winzigen Scope.
Der irgendwie die saubere wieder Entfernung dieser Schadsoftware prüft.
Das ist Kunst.
Der freiwillig
zugebe, zugibt, dass der Quellcode der Software äh zwar eingesehen werden konnte, aber ähm nicht systematisch analysiert werden konnte, weil er nur stichprobenartig angeschaut wurde und.
Was ich daran eigentlich das das größere Problem sehe ist, es gibt ja hier Verfassungsvorgaben, was diese Software sicherstellen muss, was sie nicht macht,
Ja? Und du kannst natürlich sagen, alles klar, wir bauen eine Software, die ist ein die soll jetzt irgendwie Skype abhören, also nehmen wir das Mikrofon auf,
dann kannst du kannst du den einen Test machen und sagen ja wir haben Skype-Telefonat geführt, das hat sie aufgenommen und da haben wir mal keins geführt. In dem Moment hat sie mal nicht aufgenommen. Aber was du ja eigentlich willst.
Eine Funktion, die oder halt eine Reihe von Funktionen und Save-Guards, die die.
Gemäße Anwendungen sicherstellen. Also irgendwie sowas wie,
ne also eine wo du wo du nicht sagst guck mal ob das verfassungsgemäß.
Funktioniert, sondern wo man sagt, pass mal auf, hier sind die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die Notabschaltung.
Die äh gegen den Einsatz der Software programmierten ähm.
Safe Guards, ja, die irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das Ding nur.
Rechtsgemäß äh eingesetzt werden kann und in diesem Bericht steht dann schon relativ klar, dass na ja, dass es da einfach nix äh
nichts Sinnvolles zu prüfen gab, weil man gesagt hat, wir haben jetzt Prüf, wir haben stichprobenartig reingeschaut und äh unser Ergebnis ist die Software ist geeignet, die Software ist in der Lage und die Software ist ein
ja? Diese zehn Seiten sind natürlich ein absoluter Witz. Da stehen eben diese Sachen drin. Vielen Dank, dass sie uns äh so freundlich bei Ihnen im Hause empfangen haben.
Und das ist schon äh ja doch relativ ähm relativ schwach für alle Beteiligten.
Der CCC freut sich nach wie vor über Datenspenden in dem Bereich, ja? Also Thorsten ähm hat ja auch den Digitas äh Trojaner damals analysiert. Thorsten und ich haben den.
Den Android Finnfischer Trojaner in in vielen verschiedenen Versionen analysiert und äh ja wenn.
Des des BSI und das ähm.
Des äh der BFDI und die BFDI hier keine sinnvolle ernstzunehmende Prüfung machen, bieten wir das selbstverständlich im Rahmen unseres ehrenamtlichen Engagements. Ähm großzügig an. Da sind wir ja nicht so.
Absolut äh also ich ich finde auch, dass äh diese Diskussion jetzt durch ähm Pegasus nochmal viel lauter geführt werden muss.
Also wir wissen jetzt einfach, wie gefährlich so eine Software sein kann und es braucht da wirklich Safe, gerade sowohl rechtliche wie technische und es muss auch äh Institutionen geben, die da drauf schauen.
Äh äh die die die sich auch verantworten müssen, nicht so wie jetzt hier. So äh nicht nicht, dass sich hier diese Prüfungen in Frage stelle, aber dass wir so wenig darüber wissen, äh.
Also zwanzig80 wird die frei also dann dann dann ist dir dann endet die äh äh Vertraulichkeitseinstufung also in.
2018 oder 2028.
Zwanzig 80.
Achtzig. Okay.
Dann ist das äh äh dann kannst du die schwer zum äh dann darfst du det einsehen.
Machen wir einen Kalender in weit.
Nee, also ja, ich ich argumentiere für eine Datenspende an den CTC. Ähm es ist dringend notwendig.
Gut. Ähm wir haben noch eine traurige Sache zu vermelden und zwar ist ähm,
Sven Gux letzte Woche gestorben. Ähm.
Er war jemand, den man, wenn man schon mal auf irgendwelchen Linux-Veranstaltungen oder CTC-Veranstaltungen war. Sehr wahrscheinlich ähm
kennengelernt hat an extrem sozialer Mensch, der in der Open Source-Community unheimlich
war ähm sich's auch sehr stark um um den Text Editor bemüht gemacht hat und ich habe Sven selber kennengelernt so
ganz am Anfang, als ich irgendwie so in einer Nerdhacker-Szene versucht habe, anzudocken. Ähm ich,
auch so das allererste Mal, als ich in in in Berlin war
war eher so freundlich mir irgendwie einen Schlafplatz anzubieten und so ist es vielen Leuten gegangen. Also ein extrem gastfreundschaftlicher Mensch, der extrem vielen Leuten,
auch so ein Türöffner war in die ganze Hacker-Nerd-Community,
und ähm deswegen finde ich es wichtig, dass der Tod von solchen Menschen einfach auch ähm den Eingang in so Formate wie LNP findet, ähm weil ja.
Sven auch sehr gern gehabt habe und es schade finde, dass er nicht mehr da ist. Äh seiner Hirntumor verstorben. Ähm auch recht überraschend.
Ja und irgendwann erwischt uns alle, aber ich dachte einfach so, das wäre was, äh das das hier irgendwie auch zumindest erwähnt werden sollte. Ähm.
Ob du Sven kanntest. Also er war jemand der auch hin und wieder im war und ähm äh ich weiß noch, dass er in Österreich auf jeden Fall äh Meter Lapp kennt ihn jeder.
Und ähm die andere Sache
die ich auch noch ganz kurz vermelden wollte, weil die, glaube ich, grade für die äh Hörerinnenschaft hier bei LNP ganz spannend sein könnte. Es gibt einen Call for Experts from IWP.
Äh was ist das European Data Protection Board? Das ist so der Zusammenschluss von allen Datenschutzbehörden. Also von den ähm,
Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten in Deutschland von der Datenschutzbehörde in Österreich. Von all den Behörden, die sich um die Umsetzung der DSGVO kümmern. Die haben jetzt erkannt
Shit. Unser Job ist sehr schwierig und wir brauchen technische Expertise.
Die würden wir uns gerne irgendwie ins Haus holen. Ähm es ist nicht ganz klar, ob das Ehrenamtliche oder bezahlte Positionen sind, aber sie suchen auf jeden Fall nach
Personen, die ihnen helfen bei IT-Ordits, bei Website, Security, mobile OS und Apps, Internetoffings, Cloud, Computing
ähm ähm behebt und Anonymisierung, Kryptographie.
Also ein breites Feld, in dem man sich hoffentlich sich manche von euch wiederfinden,
Wenn ihr da helfen wollt, dass so Urteile oder Entscheidungen, wie wir sie vor kurzem gesehen haben, dass Google, Schoolanalytics verboten wurden, dass einfach der Datenschutz Zähne bekommt. Da braucht es technische Expertise.
Äh Max Schrems hat das mit Neub schon sehr früh an der erkannt, weil der hat ja auch äh Technikerinnen im Haus, die ihnen helfen,
bei den Fällen, die sie ähm wegklagen und äh so geht's halt jetzt auch den Datenschutzbehörden, dass die auch merken, hey
Wir haben so komplexe technische Fragestellungen. Gegenüber von uns sind die größten Techkonzerne dieser Welt. Äh wir müssen uns ein paar Hacker ins Haus holen.
Dieser Call for Experts ähm den verlinken wir. Falls ihr euch da angesprochen fühlt, dann wäre das etwas, wo ich euch einbringen kann.
Ja, das ist ein äh immer Wiederauftretendes Feld, in dem ja dann auch, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie das bei Edry läuft, wie das bei,
äh euch läuft wie das bei Neub läuft dann doch irgendwie sehr großer Impact.
Entfaltet werden kann, ne? Und ich glaube, dass der jetzt in zunehmende Maße davon weggeht.
Im Prinzip äh die Risiken zu benennen, ja und zu sagen, oh, da kann man aber alles hier Select Sternchen äh machen. Zu okay.
Wie kann man das denn, wenn ihr das jetzt schon machen wollt, wie kann man's vernünftig bauen, ja? Wie kann man's,
ohne Blockchain und ohne Unique Identifire bauen. Weil es gibt ja diese ganzen Möglichkeiten und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da äh jetzt diese Expertise auch durchaus mal
ähm toll wäre ähm eingebracht zu werden.
Ja und ich meine, da, wo staatliche Stellen das richtige wollen, aber einfach.
Erkennen. Ihnen fehlt der technische Sachverstand, das zu bewerkstelligen. Ähm ich finde, da muss man helfen,
Also äh das das das war auch äh zunehmend auch irgendwie die Rolle in in der ich mich wiederfinde. Ähm dass man immer auch mit schwierigen Fragen kommen kann und äh ich finde,
gerade bei netzpolitischen und Datenschutzfragen muss man's zu Ende denken und und es ist halt leider sehr technisch und rechtlich und,
überfordert Leute, die aus anderen Bereichen kommen und wenn die frühzeitig entdecken, dass sie da ein ein eine eine Lücke haben und die schließen wollen.
Dann dann sollte man da immer gerne helfen, finde ich,
aber ähm ich bin noch bei einer spendenfinanzierten Organisation, ich habe die Zeit andere Leute, die damit ihr Geld verdienen, ähm wollen dafür natürlich bezahlt werden, aber ähm an sich diese Datenschutzbehörden, deren Gegner sind ja die richtigen,
äh wenn wenn die für ihren Job einfach merken, ey äh wir wir müssen die Technik besser verstehen,
Dann ist es auf jeden Fall schon mal der erste äh richtige Schritt,
Ich hoffe aus dem erwächst einfach etwas, das dann ähm ja hohe Strafen für die Datenschutzzünder dieser Welt bedeutet, ähm weil da da muss ich auch etwas am Verhalten ändern und das wird eine überreale Kosten gehen.
Alright. Thomas, vielen Dank. Ähm wir sind am Ende unserer Themenliste.
Es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass du da aus diesem aus dieser instabilen Region Europas.
Verrichten muss.
Scheint wirklich.
Das ist,
Es ist so lustig. Also es gibt jetzt in letzter Zeit immer wieder so diese Karten, wo eingezeichnet ist, dass die Grenze der Ukraine von Wien genauso weit entfernt ist ähm wie der westlichste Teil von Österreich, also so ähm äh
mal schauen, wo die Instabilität zu Hause ist. Wir aber ähm ja ähm ich,
insofern mich muss man sich keine Sorgen machen.
Um das den allgemeinen,
politischen Verfall, der irgendwie da stattfindet, denn allerdings schon, ja. Das ist äh ähm,
schön darüber hier immer wieder in den Randgebieten mal ein bisschen äh Scherze zu machen, aber was da in Österreich ähm gerade passiert, ist schon,
oder in den letzten Monaten passiert ist, ist schon wirklich schlimm äh und.
Wie es die Grenze des des akzeptablen oder des Erzählbaren oder des nicht Peinlichen die Grenze des nicht Peinlichen ja die wird konsequent erweitert.
Ja, ja, also Österreich geht nie ohne Operette
und das hat immer so diesen diesen Halbschunkgelegenheit peinlichen Nachgeschmack, aber ähm äh auch auch wenn da jetzt wieder die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist äh wofür man sich schämen sollte.
Es hat auch gezeigt, dass es immer noch ähm die die Jackson Balance gibt in der Justiz, in den Medien, im Parlament,
Kurz wurde ja auch schon einmal mit Misstrauensantrag seines Amtes enthoben.
Also es ist schon so, dass äh sich Österreich noch nicht ganz aufgegeben hat, aber äh sind halt einfach zwei Seiten und ähm die arbeiten beides sehr stark zur Durchsetzung ihrer Ziele und und ähm,
ja aber noch noch gibt's irgendwie Staatsanwälte, die mutig ermitteln gegen Politiker, die scheinbar korrupt sind. Es gibt Medien, die darüber berichten, auch äh wenn Dinge im Argen liegen und.
Das ist das ist ähm etwas, das mir Hoffnung gibt und es gibt auch noch Zivilgesellschaft, die aufsteht, die ähm genau hinschaut und äh Dinge aufzeigt, also,
heißt's immer so schön ähm ein ein mahnendes Beispiel. Äh Österreich kann sicherlich immer so ein schlechtes Beispiel dienen.
Wunderbar, ja vielen Dank, vielen Dank, dass du so vom mahnenden Beispiel äh berichtet hast. Ähm viel Erfolg ähm auch in Zukunft und ich freue mich äh dich bald wieder zu hören, aber vielleicht auch mal mit schönen Nachrichten.
Ich bemühe mich. Tschau, tschau.
Alles klar, ciao ciao.